X
RTUP SPOANC-S SP
S  AA
ICPUBLCEER SVIGAL, ON WESH ITTH
OTLER HETESIVIONVI PRO
RSDE,
NGGIVIOU Y A RRO FNTT  SOWEA
TO
MO
ACCRY.
OM>> CJOIAEDN ARSTN EWDOI JNE
OTCAADR VO HS TETOHTHLIGIG
RAVETE A WNSHOTL BREATGIN
E SEDIASEXTEAFR SUPOREO TICOX
ITRNBU P
TTHEYTIFIE EF BORUSE THHO
E
RATENSTTOM CMIEEOR FWO
HO
GTED OOAF EOORNN,E.RYVEON
THFOYOK U INJOR ING UOR F
THIMER VY T RTPOANABUNRODT
LE
USDISCONSI.
BEPR WREE  IEEOCD, LOU WLDEIK
GOVER MESOTE IMS F
OR
TEREMOTAOU RNDEBLEN TO HARESU T
V
CYOERNEAN PPATIARCIA ITEN
ME WGFINUL.AY
FIFT,RS I A YOUER EREXPGNCIEIN
COTYTIUCVIS,SS IUEE LE PASKEMA
OURESU YURR  OYOTA SFFTA CON
CT
GNDER SIECEDAT TICHNAL S
HOSO TSEUE ISSBECAS N VEES ROL
M
TO EMEURNSE ANERMBS
ICPART CANIPTSE HANAV R
USOT
ENNTGEGAMEKI , AS TTHA
IPRTPAICEMTSAN RELOTY CETIONNU
EMTO RNAILEIS VIBSSUN, LE
HY
PEEXENRICECTON CDUITIVY IUESSS
NAOR UEBLO  T OPEAPARRACAN ME
I SOAL, ATK ASTHISLL A DSDESINT
MAREINUT MEDO SKG BACUNROD NSEOI
OTESDO NPPEAHEARGIN WNHE
E MESOONS SEEL INGEASPKI
VEGILATHN E ERG N
R BEOF
ICPARTANIPTS, BWIT LL
E
CESS HY ARTOMEE AVSO
URRUSTCT
INCOACRDT Y,GL I MISYEN INTT
MO
ROD VETHTLH UGTIBYE IT TLE
WI 20  1TOTEMI0 NUOFS
DWOI ULLS ATHASO K
ANICRTIPSE RTSAIHE TIRAN H
DD
HELDOU T QHAY VENSSTUEIO
ILI WY DOL  MOSTBE T ATEERLTNA.
IT AINDDN,IO ISK TMBT HAMESER
RTD ANPATSIPICANTHEE KP REI
ONESQUTIND A CONE REFENC ATO
OUPCOLEFESIN MUT
ES ABE MNYEM AHAR VEIOUE QST
N
T ABOUUROCPRED T FESORSHI
ABUNRODT?LE
WILLEDRO PCENENDONINEEG WE,
'Y,DA IT'M  TLLRIEDO W
CE
OURMEST EEEDET VADANERS SCAVOTE
ANNSTEVERACEER SVI
ORONZANITIHITOS  TSALIR VTU
RO TABDTLEOIS DSSCU
TWO
ICCRITMPLYAL I MTAORNT TTEATRS
RAVER TE T ANSNDAMIRHE F
.
VI-SINERIC TCEOXURXP EOS.ES
'RMHA'Y,S WADEE  WMA A PMEERTT O
FCAREM  TORHEDAN PAY -ARTO-  C
E
R FO
EMTH.
PTHEY FORHAT HERECA WN TYHE
MECO H TE OM--OFOAR CE
THM
PAAND THFOY R E  CATARHEENWH T
O
E. HMEOM
RAVETEE  HNSAVENENBE DRED IECA
,
LTICING AK ACOFOLUTPROO
ITTHCELAS ENBUE RDO  T
OVE
EXXITOC  OSUPORERAVEN TE
NS
Y EVERORY,DA MMOANE D
RE
RAVETEAK SPEBOUT O A
UTAENL
POEXO RESU TNMVIENRO
ZAHAS ANOTHECTOR XI
SU DNCTAESINURG MHE TIRYITILAR
SEE.IC
CEREI'LYNT,'M EOURAOXNGGI T
D POEXSENSTEVERAARO  TSHRTHE EIC
EXS.ENRICE
ETTOM CMIEE HRD HASEA
RO M
4OVERER V00ETSAN IN  STAS.TE
ESTHEEF RNSCTLEIO ABLOR HRI
N
ULI D WOD LE TO SHA SREEOM
OUTHWI Y
OW N.
NAVYANET VER DE CRESIBWHO
EXXITOC S SUPOREOVULCOD MWHEREL
THS.EN SSE
HE WRO,TE "ULU YOCONOD TAP ESC
T
JHEETUE FL
].
YOLD COUEE SMET, I S A ILLT,
A
E IT
F AANIRETCEOR VESANER D
IBE
ALS HIDEGSIN WE H ITTH
A.V.,
INSTAT "G,ION CNUTIED
O  TE
IMPO TIBSSLEEPRO OVHA TSITT  II
E-RVSEICDLARETE
.
VEI NEEDWOR RKIT WHCAHE CMI
LS
FOBESE MREY ORICRVE IN SCE.
FEI ELE  LIKANNUA ISTH TCEO
EV.
LT HA.EAHM.YS STE
ARI HEDM  FRODOE THWIOFN A
ARANET VER S WHONOD,AI " WEIF
HOUSHLD BE AVTOYUR H
-YEAHUOLR-D ANSBDSEEC BAUF O
POS HIEXORESU TNS UE
NDCO WIOITNSN LEHI IE RVSEIC
TI
SRYOU CNT
ITS INEDIBLYLE"
CME TARO
THEDE  WNEO T PAS LTIISEGLA
N
W.NO
THREASPKEOMAS H C TTTMIED
OBR
TGIINNGSHI BL TOLOHE T F
R
WIFO,DOE  S NO  SWE BD EETO
EPAR TEDO BHENGRI T
ES BT
IBPOSSSI VLEERTH OONF ISL BIL T
H
R.FLE OO
BTHISS L ILHAHRNEGO THEGHOU T
LEEATSLIV PROSSCE,DINC ILU ANG
LLFUTTOM CMIRI HEEEA
ANGND
UPMARK
IS ITHNOS W EIM TEO T
RIG
THTOGEKE SERTAS LDHOERDAN
COE ITMMTES MBMEERCU DTOIS
E
PATH FWAORRDRE WHE IHE TRE
ONMMD RO GUNERD ANWHEEDE  WNEO
TON  DETOWSS BTORAAC TKS
.OU
RTBIR PAILANIS B AWIL LL
S
GATHE T MUOFUE ISSS ANGECFFTI
TOPOC XIEXDSEANET VER''ES ACC
REA  GCA - ANDIATR- IV
ARE
AND BSEFENITAC -- SSCEO  TA.V.
RECAENND A B
ITEFS.
IT WL OPHE UENP THAL C
EO
MORE TNHAIL.5 3 METONLI V
AS
POEX BD SETOTSN URPIND A
ISTAESBLHUM R AESIOPTNF O
AE
SELNILESOR RAES RPIRYTO
MES  ITIESON CGRTHANS D
E
ERICPL PANEOEPAC BKUAN "TH
KYO
Y FORRVR OUSEE"IC WHIT
.TIACON
TOCOS EXPER VEDETVES ANHA
D
UP PHE TIR TT AROFK. PHEAC
W,NO OT  IISN. TURUR
WEEW NOTHE  TRUF STCO OROU
ISPROM W BE,UTCANN REN
N
OURES RILNSPOIBY TO
POC-XIEXDSEET VBEANERS
UE
OFNY A PEICORENCICD VESTRKE
OV TERHEAS PEA20T  YNG, RSCOSSRE
R D ANOUUNTRHAVETHAD ME
ECH
OCEOI TPE SLL TNDRINNSIO O
OTRRI PS ITORIESEILWHE
IG
ICSERVEEMBE INT'HAO R'SAY W
C TATHETOS OF4 $6.RILLN.IO
WENO K CTHW ISS GRONESLI WISIL
O
IN FD WON MEY WN HEITTSANO T
.
TH HASEE BNSDEN MO BATTRED
YAD
25NGDI $ONIL BLIEO  TTHAST
NAEFALON DSEENHO AUTONZARITI
QUTH, E  ITIESONS- HO
CN
IWE TROMPVESHI BL ILTO EEUR
T PPSUORDANAS P
GESA?
I'REINM TEOEDST T HATR EAWHY M
GULLCOEAES ATHOSCRS EAIE SL
WODTOIK LE E HA CNGOUATTH W
T
HOL ILUPLDHI TEDSAS CR
PRE.IS
ENWHUR ORYOU CNTTOOE GS AR W,E W
N NDOOTANKEICL  TDID ME
HEDD E
NTRTPAMEF OSEEF DEN,
LDSHOUOOT N DO SHE WOMITN  C
EO
ARHE T CUROFE  OANET VER
M'I'ULATGREFVEO  THALLUF  OYO.
HEUROR F OSSIS DCUDAN IOTO
YO
GNKRAIN M IBEEMR, LOU WLD
YGIVE O TOUHENIORPPTUAD TO
N
INMEY ANULGF R.AREMKS
NKRAGINBE MEMNK TR:HAMROU Y,
.
AIRM.AN
I W TT ANTOVENKHA EFOONRYE
RJO
INING U THES RE
AYOD.
I'G'M  TEFATUL OEAO CHFOYOF U
ROU-  -RFO YROUTMOM CMI
T O
VEOUR .RATENS
YOMI COMENTMT RRESES
RSUNDEG NDTAINALE THCH
NGLS
DPOSEY BOXICXPOSEUROOLL A T
WE
IS D TSSCUEDSEHO CGELLHAENS
UNSTLA J
ITCOE MMETEAS WULAI PNF
DERPD PAREREE  VTOOTIL AON BY
T
TTHANT POI
WOER WE ONINRKG  AIM MIN
STNF IONMAORTIND A
VEEC REIUMCO
RANCSIO LEERO FBITHM E NDE
STMIADNI.TIRAON
WEE  HOWAVF MESO OETH
ATFOINRMN,IO AIS INDT  WLE CAR
A
E  MVEORRKWO T
DOO .
PRI APIAECTEHE TOU RE TANDBL AAS
STRSFIT T , EPBUTHVEGIN EOC FUS
TOCU DISRY ESSVEWEINTHG TOEE ND
DATO
MP EXA L, LEWEELIKY WTL ILNO
HA THETUPP OORO TYNI TSSCDIUS
ETH W NEWE K ORTHA. IDOIN
GD
RET BTERTUP SPO EOX TIC
V.A. RTIT ENACOUS ONSH
URRMFO OONOR WK HI TSSS I,UEIN
NOCOMPE WI
ITHT.
ASAND E H IAV SAIBEFO
, E
TNEED AWOO RKSAR PERTNSN  O
APA
PLLRAELTHH ATWIOTAC EH RHE
DAN T SEN GE ATTOS TETHI DE.ON
E  HWEAVNET NODOTHHA TT US FAR.
D OU TWOR RKOPO SUPIC TRTOX
POEX-RESU -XP EETEDOS VHAANERS
S
SUFFOREDER FT. I
ISTND UERE D ANTH INASETE
Y ENRRTLINPLEXORG ADHA PSESCU
CHPRAPOADRO  TADXIS ESTO
CEX
TSUPORETOU WLDOR PRI
IE
FCARESE TORHOEEHO W NITD . NOW
OFOSTHE O S  UWHEDTEATND
AST
'YEARL'S IVSLGIATE HRIEANG M
AY
MBREME JERIMCE PRIS''ONSTTEIM
I
COMTET VHOANER WSE WEIF
TR
LYICAGALD AS PSEROAYAW F
MCO
NSITNDIOYIK LELD IN LKE
TOTO
CXIURXP EOS
KNYW NOMAYO OF EDWOU RKIT W
HA
NDENUR AR. MEA DYRL
QTOIMTEUO JS''ONSTTEIMY,
AD
T'IF IS AREAT GRE"B -- SEFENIT
ARRE GT , ATBUEAEYTH MOT NNGHI
EO STOOMNES HO W IECADDE BSEAU
IDEYTH DETOT N GAR C"E.
JIM PPE IUTT Y.ECRFTL
WED  NEETO OOC FUSNGTAN KI
STIACONOWPSTE NPAO  TEXND CEAR
SE TTOHOEEHO W NITD T MOSOR BEF
T
O S  ITO
TELA.
ONDIADTIWELYAL,  NTI SLLDEE T
FYENIDTI AO AY W TR Y PAFO
C
SUEXPOREEG LONLAISTI
THE CBOST EATESHE
OUCT A W
STLYOU RGHBI28 $0 IOLLN I
W
ATMANDYORND SPEGIN A 1
$7
IOBILLINN EW NETIS DCR
NAIY
DISPEN.NG
NO DWEO E  HAVDSNDHUREF O
NSLLBIIOLLF  ODOS ARINFFSE
TS
LARONGYI AD.UN
-- A $147ONIL BLIWN  INE
DIARTIREONDISPY EN.NG
I BEWEEVLIE EE ND TOSE PREERV
ETOFFSTOFOS R POC XIEXNDRESU A
E T LETHBECUFOS T. THA
I OMINMA C TTTMIEDO FWAD INA
Y
UPTO SOXRTPO TOS-EICXP
EDVE
IRATENSA WATHATS I
SCFIESLYAL RLENSPOIBUTOR F FEUR
TINEGERAS.ON
EVBEI LIE E W TN CADOT.HA
NGEASPKIS  AAER VETAN MELYSF, I
DOT'T ATK INTHOS  ITO M
O
ASK.
RAVETENSRE AYEAX TPA,RS
OO .
HOWE SD ULBE M ODFINULWEHOF W
SPDEN TONIRHE MTH OEYN REI
.HABELF
EACHF OOU YRAN ORGNSATIZIOREHE
T
N BE O TL ALOFSEHEMS ITETOND A,
BE HESONTIN, TOB RUSSSIS DCUNIO
NEETO HISE AVTHER AFTONNO
THOUABT E T WAY FMOO VE.WAORRD
THU,K ANYOHAR. M C FMAIRN,
ORHA
NGVIROHI TS LEDTUNAB,ND A
WA FOKORRDISO  TTHSSIS DCUNIO IO
DATO
THA I YACLDIE B
CHKAR AITA:NONK THAOU YINRA, NK
E
ERMB.
NWII LLRO IOWNTCE O
PAANICRTIPTSM  FROTEE THVENS
ADCYCAND A PMU CSOOMTIES
GINJOIN U ATHS ISONERFTNOMR IS
O
AR SHNTUER VT,ETANOC ADVE.AT
HN. MRJOS,IE FLDANET VER
S
TEVOADCA
MSE RO. SITOPELOZ
ESRR,
UTEXECEIV DRECIRTO, . PA
K
AYMURRCTDI, REOR OF NLIOATNA
INUTITES OF S TVIERCE
OVE
ORATENSIGFOF RENAR W
FOSR
ICAMER TA,HEEPUTONNAY TI
ALLE
IVSLGIATE DR ECIRTOABR FOST
ICERAN VSERETAN,
LTON CSU
R
VIVENAETM  ARATENS,RIMECA
LIY CRCHUH,R. MLE AX
SK MIRY,
TYDEPUTOIR DECOVOFR  GTNMEREN
S FAAFIRWADEUNR IORRRJE PRO,CT
.MSGE BURRNGO, VEELNTME R
S
COAND ATUNMMIC ANSIOTEOCSSIA
,IR
ANDFG AANNIHASTANET VEROFS
A ERAMIC-- MS. BCHIR,
SLLEGIASIVATE E CISOATETH
ANERAMIC L MIOEGN,Y  CR.OR
,
CTDIREORF  ONSTEVERA BSEFENIT
SED ANREERVFF AILRSAI M
ARIY
RSFIOFCETH, TAMIE LIIC ORYFFSER
CIASSOIOATN, MCO RR.OSBUTL,
CIASSOGIE ATLEEATSLIVIR DTOECR
AND J MR. VAL NAT
NAIOL,
ICSERVCTDIE REORTEF  OVENSRA
TSNEBEFI AIC POLNEALY IGDITH
E THOSATSOASCI
NSIO.
THENTER TT ESOFDE IMAN
O
TKEEPNGHISIN MOVOU IG, WE LLDIK
TO BEG D OINURIOCUISSSTUANN D
O
IT TLE O IF THE
IL BL,
NSEXPA HN IOOFLTEAHAR C
E
IBELIG
ITILY.
CAYON UHA SREOUHE T WEDND
RRRWAIOCTRO PJE''ECER PSP
V?
YO IOU SNDL STS IL
--
C H YANOU?R EAME
WAI NT TK THO ANR U YOFOGLDHOIN
RTHISBLNDOUTAEORND A FINNV IIT
S
RTO  TPAE IPICATIN TSHI
SCDI OSIUSONNHE TIL BL
WE
NGSTROPO SLYUP.RT
IAN WTATOT  SAC BRTY DGOWKNLEGIN
EITHRK WOR MLLY ANBISCERONTDU
COHI TS ,RENGSSOUND A Y
AE
THPUT ET TEMOGRHE TTECRO EA
COTS HERINLUF  OSOONTIS
FR
RAVETE W WNSHOEER EOSXPED
.
EWHIL WHE TREE MASAEC NES
R
NSISOVIOISN  ITHTHIL BL AT I
KNLLE  WWISCE  BDI
SIUSNG
Y,TODAHI WCH ILUDE
SCALIFNTICE, MLYORE H IAV
O
TALKBOUT IIT TLEH WH, IC
D
PAEXMA PNDEREANTNE HHLTTOAR CE
ALNSTEVERAERHO W WE E
OSD
NGDURI MHE TIRY ITILARERVSEIC
RE OLERDSSF DITABISILYLA CS.IM
WE BIEELVES  THITI CISRIOTL,CA N
ONETOR F VANERS A
EALRDY
ERSUFFOMG INFRURXP EOSTEREE-LAD
SELNILES F BS,UTMRO
A
ARPREPSTIVATE NTDPANOILLS  AWE
D WOI ULO KELI TOUINPOT T
HT
NAVIETRAVEM TEE  HNSAVENRMPEAN
EDANARTESCC AES TOLT HEA
E
TODUE URXP EOSEENO  TAGGEORT AN
U
ENRRTET VNEANERS  TEDHEE SAM
AC T FSSORE SHEAMNSEA RSO
.
IIF, OU CLDIOU WE  LLDIK
TOILY
TESTLURAOIHE T PBR BNTY
INTELLGOU YTOHE T SUT ARYBO
A
RRWAR.IO
WAOTSCT AS AR MO E INWHEDPLDEOY
ICTWFGTOE  AANNIHASTCOS  AA ATMB
ERGIENNE AND DDL HOGANERRE WHE
HEOS EASXPBU TEDO S. PRNIT
NT SHEPEWIIM TE  D TTHHE
SO
IFSEE COHE TY DUL SNILLTI S
EUN MFRIOITN  B TOMHE
NIG
STWAE.
BUTHE  PITWEREASSE UD
ATR
NIAING A HA REINISE. CAS
EVALLYHE WOR HASONLYAB
HADISC
EDRG.
HEEV NT  FERELEDE THNEROO  TEN
N
ME.A V. CADILAR CE OINPUR T
I
TYBISALI CECIMLA BESEAU H FTEL
ATTHSU HE  NERFFEDO SCANIIGFI
T
SABI.TILIES
IT U NASOTIGILNT ERS YHTEA
LAR ING PR SINE 2020 HDARSTTE
EXNGENRICIE EV SERNADOABMI
INND AG OS LIN RIGWEHT,IDAPLYLPA
ANATHA TT,POT INEWE  HKN
THSOMES G INWAONG, T TRY
OEN
NLLRO I HAL LISOC B.A V.,
UT
ARLEDNE HNOWAE S IBELT IG
LE,I
NE NCHEILEREV F AEDLA CIM
EDHAENNCBILI EGIERTYLI PDIOOR F
COER VATETS.AN
HEEROV TOURSOF THE NTEX
RASEVEHSMOL NTTSC, OT
LACUACMUD ABT $2IN000,0
MELCA BEELSIL SIANGKI D
S
TRAND T TMEAENRFO HIS CONDIONTI
AN N WITASIL UOTNT TAT LERTHA
AR ARIEND S WHOWIVEERD
THO
D ECNNTEMHIUNO  TWODDE WRIOR
PR
ECOJT.
ERWE W TABE LEGEO T HIM
RVICCONN NTEECD, H FOTOR
IO
POC XIEXRESU, B O FUTORERTH
, INTHGSROD ANENEDLL IN. V.A
HI DISGNIAOS M F AEWLATHONS RTE
SMI TERNCL NAPA CATREIC
.
TADEUNRS, ABNDLYNO CHEAN
HP
T BU INDWOERCAHIF S OUERNC W
LD
N VEHA ALEEROPAB WF  IIT
ONHTUG MSTHOO SENR NEWHE HASCA
LLITINIAD TRY IEOL ETONR
MRRMCH. AI, ANWEIE BELVE NL.
OVE
RATEN I WHOINSES RVING  A
NAR
KN OEAF PON OWEXREDHO SUL
EVRNE  BTUY  AEDWAHEOMFR T
A.V.
UNATRTFOUNOTY ELSCOTIST  N
ONALE.
WE EIMATEHE T A AREREMAS NYS A
IGINELLEIBOR F VAL. .AHEE CTHAR
HAVEEE BNE NA UBLAB ETOSTSHLI
E-RVSEICTENNCOECD DITABISIL
YWI.
IVINTH FERS YEASCF  ODI
'ATTH'0,S 75TE0 00VENSRAHO W
IRVSEEDNRE AKN OASF N
EXHORESU WRE APEOW N O
TG
OUWITHFEA T SATY NUL SETHO TYHE
ICOBEMED, LLANDO WE T'N'
IK
OFANY  TOUM HESH EVEBE
EDTURN AKEY WALI WCO STT.AS
THFOR SO RISEAST WN,E
NGRY
EVBELIE TART HAGUTEANEDSCC AES
N CAORRECA FXPOSET VANERS
-
CAAND  E FREOR VOSXPEDS ERETAN
LYLUSOTETI CRIL S AND
UD
ARBE PTY F  OANXITOCXP EEOS
FTILUONNGM ROCO
SSRE.
ONIN ACEGAI, OU WE  LLDIK
TOTH
KANOU, . CH ARMAIANN TNDUR
ITKACTOVE OR TOU Y AHI T
SPO
T.IN
AICHR KATANO: THA YNK FORHA T
E
Y.IMSTON
ITY  VASERARHETENDENGO T
HAARHE TY.STT OR
I WIOW N
HESK A T
IR FST
TIQUESER UONNDIT TLE
I.
E TLI ITIUPS DA
TNGHE
TIFIDENITO OONF POC XIEXRESU
SKRICT A TITIVY,UA AHECT
GENGLAUAE N  ITH
LLBI.
BA IITS Y CASILLFIE THDE,TINION
SOINTHGT THA EDYRYVEBO HEER
,
RIMINO MEMRS, TYJOMARI
S,MBMEEROMSO P CNIMUTYDV A
S
AN-- CVEE  WLIIT WHTOHI TS CXI
REPOEXSUISND A RVIACK TI
TY
TIFIDENION
NYE, M AITCT AIVY-  -S  TISHI
A
VIREHAONSI TWET  S CANPORT
E ARANERTHE ERCOY NC?NS
ISNYREHE AHODYBO WAN CTNO
T PPSUOR?IT
IGATTH MHTE ANASIETOWAR Y
REOND.
ISRE THEDYNY ABOANHO W CTNO
T PPSUORISTH REVED DEFN?ITINIO
YE
.HE AADO
>>HA T, YNKOUAI. MRCH
ANRM.
TDOESSHIIS REVIN DEDEF
IOIN
ALLU ISONC TDEHEES DATND A
ONCALOTI ATHS ATTE LREIS I--N
LII BE IE EVITIOSES CT
30N?
AICHNOTAR KA: TSHI R
ISEVED
NIDEFIONTI -NO- ,DO IT
NT
UDINCLS.DAE TE
NOTEF. OS SOWEINTHG D HO SULKETA
L  WWEILHAKETA TRUNT DE
USDISCONSI AP  KNDEE
INTHGS
MOVI.
MR. VEALU , YOVEHA A CNNTME O
TII?E
.MR VHAE:AL T,  YNKOU.MR
ANAICHRM
FITRS,  OFF TWAI NTWISAO Y
THU
ORPPTS THI LTIISEGLAON
.
SOI ALTOAN WT  OOI PNTUTHA TTT I
ISOOOT N GDY OL PIC
ISPREROMUNANE D LIR DEDER.VE
HIIF TOTISS  NE  DONRRECY,
OUWE C RLDUNHE TOFIS RK
INPEREATTHE NS OPATHF E .ST
OFLOA T OOD
PL PEOELO-  -A OFT
ODGO PPLE RKV. AT
AAD
R THEIARNDHAS NOFE TEIE TD.
GOLAEG LISVETI I
ENNTT
TISOMEDSS MEENP U WH
MARULEHANGKI TTTSES RULN I
NDINUNTESE CEDONS.ENQUCE
VHAS  IINEROPATULATG  F
RCIPATYHTIGOW NCO, ACINRDG T
U
RSUNR DEG.NDTAIN
WHDEON CSIHENGRI TXNF ILUF O
ENEW,E GILIBLNSTEVERA
HI TS
SLLEGIIOATNIL WIDPRL OV IFOE R,
N
LY NEE SMS TURATALIST HATHS I
OTORE GAT AN UR BDEA R FOVH
TO
BEAR I
ELTSF.
EQCONSHENTUE T,FA IT
S LLN
UNCOMMREY ITCAETWOS TO
RLIDEVECALTEAH VE TREO .RATENS
S  TISHIOTOAT GREDE B AUR
FR
COTHE Y UNMMITRECAWO NET
SO
?BEAR
E S HATHLLFUT COSNDO  TFU
HS
ADALTIDIOND EM DANALR FOHE
THCA
REN  BEEERNSCOID?ED
SISTH I HNGPEAPNIIG RHTOW N
.
ENPEDENDCERE A TEI BNGNED
Y
MFROMY ITILARENEATRTM
ESLICITIEO  TTHNIOM CMUTFA
-
ENPEDENDTS B ARENGEI T
NEURD
AW.AY
N W HOCAEYTH HMODLANE
SENTITS TH UCASHEER VETSEPA
ELNDLEIB UERS THI LISLAON?
ARWE UTINTNIEN CALONLYGATREIN
A ECRFTTORM,  SVIGINGYEBOMOD
A THFINET NO CEYANTCCES
TH'SLL REATRFRY US SINATG,IO ?
K ASRFOASEP RHRGIN
AND
RFUNDEMADEUND
ATNDE.
PO SWEUP TRTHELAEG LISUTONTI B
ARNENCCOERTABD OUAV HGIN
G NDFUINPO STOUP
IRTT.
THU.K ANYO
CHNOTAR KA: YHA TNK.OU
DWEELINEFITHAY VE YOT NEDROU
NSNCCOER
T MEON GO  TINRAO NKERMEG MB
STBO.
INRANKERMEG MBOS BT: YHA TNK,OU
.MR CN.IRHAMA
THS  IAST QUEWAN IOI  TNTO A
V
Y YBERODS ATTH IEDVOINLV WHIT
ITLTIE  HE.ER
YOULWOD E AGU REATTH AINREDDSS
L
ITIBIGILFOR ALTH CEAR
BOUSHLDFIOUE R TRSOR PRIY?IT
RY EIFVEGRDYBO AS,EE I W
E
ON, BYO IUTF'DOU N'RET AG
T
NOME KWT. THA
THINS  IGOGADO  TLE TMYO
COSENDUE Q
IOSTN.
ENTH YOU WLDPO SOUUP ART
OSPROPT  TALHASTEEXND
ILIGELIBRY ITFOE  CARTTHWIOU
EXINNDGEN B--ITEFS UTIT WHO
INPAEXNDGITEN BEF
TH OERDS WORHETO,  T ON
NG
STATENT ATTH I WAD ME,SCHHI I
THS'E' TOPPELEEDT HANEHE T
RECAOW NSO, ' LETM'S WA FVEOR
I
T, TTHHADERO PVI TT HAAT A
LELHA TANWET  CHEND A T
NCO
TINNTUEOOR WKOW TED ARTH
LOL  GEROAISR FOTHIL BL
.
ANDIODYBY  WGRSAEEATH ITTH
?
J>> ITUS HE A T.MMCOEN
MYCEONRN IS HOWELL-EDUIEQPP
ISHE.  V.ATOANDLETHE OS
COTIX LEPAOMTSEN CG ININ WHIT
YIDEUNRLNGEA DISATS SETHP U
TIUNL NY TOWHE P ARE OSIASNG
OSSY PCHATOMIC I
UESSS?FS
ATHEYGN DREIAPEINOSG LEOP WHIT
HNTMEALISLTEAH ESSU ASEOPS PO
HETO TER USENDINLYG C TCEANRSTHA
LLE ARKIGIN VS.ERETAN
I E  GLLIVU YOANLEXA EMP- -
NTRGSEEASDED WNEAYCK BLA,
WO
WAS OSTJON N'AREWT'OWS SH
RE- LYNT -HEIE D
GE BMYIGCE CSTONLD WRNOUE B
T
NITRAILD WNGOUCIE  BFAD TALITE
H
EES CANNILICI
THARE EYRA TN EDIN ITICUOCPAALON
NEDIMECI
AR TTHE EYINRAED I
NEP
LOEMIDIO?GY
ERTHE IUCSOS  MAKITH  T
TEO
PR AEROPLYTHECFFT EESDS KINF O
HESSTHAL IS.UE
OUATTH W BNLMYE  OYCE CON,RN
ON IIS DT''ONTWA THAEE S WIST
ENHAPPW G INNOUENTCOINO T
HA
ENPP.
RAMEINNKG OSERMB BT: T
T HS
ABPROB O OLYNERETHF E ONASS
Y
S IT IAL VSOITOR ILYMPNTTA T
OGE
THT ENP IM  FUTROA.E THV.SO
KWEERW NOWHTHE EY,  AREATWH
ANEYTH CE,AN HDLUT B AOLSAS,
TH IIDN INOPE ENGTE STANTMEN
IA
OUSTLARI HEAIL, NGWHREWEE  A
DO,THG ISE E  WARINDOGHI NOT
ATD ANTHT S  INO PGOA ODCELA
TOE B
AN C CW GUANM DAL W
O?
D CWEANTHO IS A PROORDEVI F
THTHE AT HD E AVAN
N CABE
NODIAGDSE ALL SNDTINUON CTITOE
NRKWO OHE RATISEGTRTHN IORA
ANTHU -  -YOTADEUNRST  WNDHA'I'R
YISANG
?
'THATT'S ERCOE NC.HEN RE
CHNOTAR KA: MR. BIWNRO,
UN YTARSNDE  HOUAVANSES RPO
.RO B:WNSEEP RREEATNTIV
OS BT
,
ESA QU HONTI IULE AVWOHABED  W
B
E T OUTH WOPPELEE HHOAVHE T
ALRMTEINCE CAN A ARSNDBL URENA
O
K? WOR
HOULWODHE TNSOM CPE--IOATN
, WHELD WOUMET  ICO
?
INRANKERMEG MBOS BT:T' TH'ST WHA
I'YIM SA.NG
WEONAN C CTONUTIE OR WKTR TO
YO
HAET G TDONEQU AS ASKLICY
LESSPOIB BTO, O, S TUTHEONUAITTI
DO WISE NO KWHO TT  TSEHAEAR
D.POEXSE
WEOWO  DKNHO TSENEHA TT
E
CAMEDITMTRL EAATT ENTHCAHE TY
N
E CEREIVGHRIT N.OW
M CWEANRWE OVFOTHD ARWINGET GTI
THAR PT OUT AEN TNDAKAR CE
F O
D TH CON
NUTIE.
O WE DITATTH WSLLEH GI
IOATN
EREVYAY D
ATTHS IE OW H W
EACRTE
GILEN,ATSLIO OUI QTEEN.
OV MEWA FORWI KRDNONG T
E
CAN FINILYTEIVOS PIT
Y EO
,THISND 'ET L'EPS KENGOR WKIO T
TOTRY  I GETERBET TT B AND
R
ARE INT NODOHIANG YT.NG NWE,
MR.WN:  THAG GOT IN
O
TBACKO EOV CERLIARER VSERETAN
FREF BE1 9/1 WH THKNOW
X
SSUPORE T.  VHE.AS HAONIR THE
WEREE ITALY,ADR ISHAT
SO FLYORHE T9/OS PT
RAVETE?NS
CHKAR AITA:NO MRSUNY DEGNDTAIN
ISHA TTT WOD S DRADESETH
/1STPO-91 VERS,AN P NOT1-9RE/1
VE
NSRA.
SIT I S ABETEYSM EAG INCRDTE
OMW,NO SHINGEING DEON
O.
N'I DOT'T  HK INWETAE AVDA
R
9/PRE-11
ET VS.
MR. BI WNRO: TADEUNRST WNDHA
Y' S ARERE
INAYG.
THE.  V.AY REALADSHA TWN KHENO
SUEXPOSREDIS LTEEVR  OPRUSIO
TMPOAPINTSEF B11E OR9/
'THATW'S AS IAT WDE WONNGRI, I
H
ULE OSWOBED ED ADDTHNT IO
E
EMSYST
AICHNOTAR KA:HE TARY ELA P
G
T T--HAS  ISOAL IENTHN E
AE
--NOW HE TAVON CCL
NOE W.
ANDOI  WEETOT  KPHI TNGMOS VI
.
. , XTMSS.TKWAIN
AD AGOHE
.MSAT WNSKI:RE A IPP
ATCIE
EV BYOERNEERNGEI HE, OD TAY
I
KTHINVE E WBORYDYO TSAN T
E
TRIGH AHI TNGE  MNDAKRE TT
THBUE RNS PIT PLATIARCU
Y F
THET POSGE/1 91 ONRANETI
DS
NOTIV LUGTHE ROTHE ME
RIEXPEHACEEN TTUR OTN VIES VAMET
WHNTWE T AOUHRGHRANTGE OENG
NTWEOU THR WHOENT HROTHUG
YESND A OEA YRSF S ADITUES
NE
ONNDMAS IR THEIME  MAK
SER EICAN I T.  VHE.A
ILWE
OPPE DIERO FSUEXM PO.RE
WERYRE A TG INTOVO A REPTING
RENTIS HRYTO,ND ARE A IPP
E
YOEVERNG BNEEI HER
IE  HAVA PAROF TL  BHEILATTH
AWERE CRISIONDE.NG
REPRENTAETVETI PER MERAYND A
I
BUTHD E  E PRNITEOSXPURCT A
JUKEO  TMASIT  IEA H AERNDEAV
SORE PONMPSUTIHE WNALOU Y W
K
IN
SLVIOBOUCO IY,T SSTEY MONO T
PEEATRT HOLEOP WBEAV HE
EN
EXPODSETH TO INE ESTH.GS
KTHI IN WKNALE L P  DOWEEWNDO
TH IATTS  IF RTPA OROU
SISPREON, LIBITYDANLD W IOUUS J
O
M FTEOREACOY LLN ESGU OETH
OHEOTRSAITHF E OE SLWHORE A S
WODIE AHEUTBO T, ON MEYLALUT B
ONVOYOF U DTE FOR T
$HE5
NLLBIIOASNC IREHETOE  TSEEF DEN
BU.ET
JUSTBE TO STON CSIRET ENHE,F I
YOINE ARGOG DO  TBE
PLEEY
ERCONCDNEBO A S TUTHEGNDPEINF O
MOOU IY, WLDEC EXPTHT E SEAM
NYRUSCTIBIO  TA  YSE POUAS
DED VOT DN  OINR EMECBEEATTH WAN
ARWNO GINIVGHE TO OUINLPG
RVE
.RATENS
D WOI ULSTJUOSSK A R Y, IEIF
OU
CO JD UL--TUSM  FROURYO
ENPEEXRI, YOKNOWI, HI T
T
S IS IMEMESOTIHAS RDYOHE WN DOU
LICYOUS JT- - S YOU
T F
LOSEOURBI AO TYLI TTADEUNRS
H
S TATHI FEA MNSORUM HAN
BE.GS
YKNI OWPER OUEX TENRICE
OH
HYOUR WBAUSNDLL RASEAYOW P
L
IWHEN IEA HRD
TAUT ALKBOIS EERIEENC O
O NGYI TISKEMA H CD E ASANATFTR
IT SEA MNSO TIST HATHTTOM CMI
E
DEUNTANDWH V OATURSERETAN
ARTHINGOG  EUGROHRYVEAY D
T
ETTO GREHA TT IOGNCOIT
MS.SOR TRE, WE: LLOKLO- AN
UK ANYOMU SO EV TCHO
YOE
THFOR OR OISPP.NITUTY
ITS  IANARYES S.YED AR
I ITEDRK WH V THE..A F
S,YEARSOO  SI  ORTFER UND
OD
RETHE DE TAP WE WOUE ERABTOT
BUCEFA, ITT AS W AEA YRSRS YNDEA
OFAY OOT BHHE TTMEP DARTEN
OFEF DHESEEN TTMEP DAR
T EF
RAVETEAI ANSFFRSE. SID
WE BLYICASALTOEN WT
VE ERY
HEAL CARE FYILACITHI WIT
E
EMSYST
ROTO POI AVE PD, NTANMOHE TN
M
TLRTPOAN TY,ORY TTO  TGE
ANS,?IG RHT
I KNADREY  TEWHE O WCOUTME
AO
G INTO BEN EVE OE R VETHRKWO
JURYENTE
EEBETW, THN AT N HWEADITPRONOF
ZAGAORNIFIONTIS INLLGHE TAP G
IANAFINCCAY LLBEEUSHA WE
ADYAU EXHUREDST O
IF LE
NGSAVI
MINY H'BAUSN'S CT E,AS ISWA
MOREF  ONG BUSEID OR FCE
D
NSAN ARWEEC BSEAUMPIS H E
YR
WAINGES TTYREG ADT O  TLEMHI G
I
T?GH
HE S WASOLTETA P TE ICINHE STETA
OFEX TD , ASANEN TY FOEDRC
M HITONES RIGFT AFI WERE
LY
AWERE RE BLTO AEIECVE
OL D
SIAGDINORO FDRM .ER ROB
RIL MLE
OVNDT  AVA UBIERLTITVENIRS
YR
R IOTO TT, ERY AWAWENSR
U
ST BLYICASALGN D AIAISOSF O
N KNUNOWGYIOETLO, AIENXTY.
ITERAS W VTRFRY US
INATG.
KWEATW NETHE WNOER WE
THTE
AMLYON FPEY ILEXNGENRICI
HIS
RDHASOIPSH,  YFT AEROUSTXH EAU
ALIFURYO LEAV SN GSIN I
G
CCTO ASESE CAR, WEICWHH RE A
ILSTLT  SORRE TOFHE
ASHE WTLEC RENYOS HZETAPILI
R
SATHE ME IASUESSS HE TTL GENANEM
ALS EKMORKE TKYALT.ABD OU
WE'O' IKNT OWASHEF  H
PA CATREIC
CEANR.
S IT IIBPOA SS
ITILY.
CHTHE ESLEALNG FHE TSEILIE
ASCEFA, OME IDFRG RY TIN
ARSSCE CYO IE,S  SHEU ARRYTOAC
STTEAFR  TY OROFURSEHE S'VOVIR'
SDOWIWSGNDPEIN LHE TIRYST ASDA
HETHWI TOVIR LEDRYNE O T
GO
EACRTE SON MEYNTTETAME
RO FM
EITHD LOR V'ESON'TH BRODS ERAN
ERSISTNGDUS RIMEAR WTI J
TO
REFIGUOWUT O HO PUFOODN O
ETHLE TABOR F THIIRHE C
RELN
TONCEIR LED OE S NEAR
.
WEITNO KW NDS  IHADLE
N  OA
-BCASE BCAY-SEISAS, BT  TUTHA
S
NOGHENT OU
S VERY SCAINO  TTHTABK OU
GOG TOHE T.A V.
IR TENHETAWN O SLS TFFELS UF I
YORIVEHA TRECA, TO  GON
HEOU
IDTSE.
S ISTH IOWEITHR NTA SIN GFFIV
G
INISTH KOFD  AANICDVE
D
COURT.EMAGEN
WH KIE E W NOTHSA.V. IKI WOR
N
S,HI TNGHE TTYEA RLITH IS
AN
COHI TS Y UNMMITPL POFEO
E
IMCTPAED, OWU YOKN,HE T'R'
SNE
THHEITR ESU PRE NTIMPON
E
THHEALAR CEPE HAPNG.
KNI OW VS ERETANAVATTH HEDWAE LK
INNTPP AOINTMES AND TAVY HELE
O
.LEPESS
I D'O' HKNT OWY  MOWAN
OPPE
VEHAUT P ALE BULHEINT  TD HIREA
CAUSTHE EY AHO SREO  ALEPESS
H
OFENE D HE T. DAY
EY AIN LREOSG TIRHEES HOM
,TH
HIR EIVETHESCL, REIOBS.
SOH UCSO TT HA-- I AND
ILL
WIEND S  TTHHI--HE TNJ U
TS
NDBEHIF LL A OISTH IS
ROLES'Y'SSB JOLOIL WLEOW N B
HED BEHEREFO TSU.S U.
EME
URCOT B IAUECSEOTIST  NTO OK
TRRAVET TE W TNSHEY  TAYHEVEHA
REENBE T
INATG.
SO IT JUSRANC EOU FRORY EVE
CTRSPEPEE E,IV WOLVEHA C
CD
TADAND AHE TRE AREPL PEOINE
Y EVERCTSTDIRIG OM CINDRWFOAR
DANIN SAYE G SANG TMEHI
.TH
U.K ANYO
>>HA TNK, YOU.MRTUART -
-TH
U,K ANYO.OS RIE
MR.WA STERT
IANT  STOAY?
WE AS RE A
G LKTAINFUOUABT ANINNDG
AINTTG REIF DFENT PTISPERECE
N
LDSHOUE. BREE ALHIOFY  T
AVEYTH HECTOE  D TE IDIFREHE ARE
I--NHA WT ISER GENEELYAL SASN
MME THCOITY  ANER ADV
L
ESPROCTHS AT CANHEIE T T
POEXN RESU INDAQIR AFG AANNIHAST
TODI CHEONONS EY A
RESU
GERFFIN NOW.
E THER ROUSHLDONLLEAY ON BLYE
E
JO
HODOW E WLE IMPIRNTME FST R
CTOXIOS EXPALE URHETH CRE ARFOE
TH AIRE AQHA ANDFG
STNIAN
TEVENSRAEYO  STH CEI REC
N
THE WAYHA TGSTHT INGOAV HE ENTT
TTBEER WHITATRA TUMIC
RA BN
INIFRYJU, ENOU Y WTOW DSYEN AR
AGUT AO,MPD S EEANW NOIT
IS
D-WORLSUASCLS S,ERRGIE
WOASD-RLCLSHERO PSTANCSTI,
D
RITED  R A--NDITABEHIL
I.
ITBUT  TKOOTTENNDONTI A
Y
D ANE  HWEAVTOLIST EABT TSHHA
FOTEE THVENSRAAQF  OIRND A
AFTAANGHISNSEEC BAUHE TOS CT
SYEARAT LD, ERAN YET BDEURN
F
F PROORUD ANSCNY IALWA
N
THEANET VER
WEHE WN AL TKBO AUTAN WONGTI T
GEM  THELT HTOEAHE CAR N,OW
TCEACSSSTA O SYT  TEMHAOTESDO N
DEUNTARSND EOX TICE OSXPURESDO
LPT NOHEE.NY AON
ERTH BISE  ANURENIT P CRR TEFO
EXLLENTH ACET .V.E A.
THNGUN FDI IS 6ONIL MLI
MIYEIOLLN .AR
EA15 YRSER AFT D THEW  KODNEIS
STCOWAM S
NGMI.
THEYND SPE $LI M90ILEA AON YONR
,AGVIRAT  JUSE GTOIV
YOU
PEPERS
IVCTE.
IFUDGES  IAIS LOUOFT  Y
RPR
ESRIIOTI,NK T IHIHIS OWS
WHERY EVESTINTHG
DSAN.
A.E THV.RAS  IAFBE OIDF GIN
EROVD.ELWHME
ALAND COTHL E TIERNVSA
S OE
LDSHOUE B HING-  -LYE THON
COONSAERTIE SHE LDOU B
G
ISLA C AOLVERABOTITFF EOR
TO
G BRINA.E THV.HEOG TET
ANR D
EACRTE-RIR FSTXIE ATTOCURXP EOS
E
THALE CARNO, FIBET NEER LTSAT
BE YE USIF S AOUREKIC WHIT
ATNCPAREICRAN CCEOT NGAV HIN
YOITEN BEFWHATRE Y
OULI
N?NGVI O
I TSOHE HA DEWEEAVO T S
ITEV
NGYTERHID P  UAN MEACRTEEOR
CRREBUAUROICAT P ISSCEES
S
ACCE.ABPTLE
TTE THBOE LOMINR S  IOUYUNCOTR
EXRD SEOUER VET PS ANTO
SN
FOR YANRSEA, NEWED  KTABW OU
,
WEAND OTID D NCT AIT WHRG UCYEN
PRD ANAPENRIOPATS.ES
ORERTHEFHA WE,E VEOS LT A MEN
O
O N MEWH TRVSEEDUNS HICOY.TR
EYTHDIAV HE  FRO OUR
CT INAN
.
US ISO JT W ST ANTOCKP TEBAOR F
NDSEA COND 'ON D'RRT WOUCSOY  M
B
ET OUTHRO PCOLHIND A TSNG
HAKELI T
S'T'SET NOLOHE BIGTU PIC.RE
I KW EVYONE TAN WTSHEDOO  T
ECAPPR BTEIAD, IUTT O  DNONTWA
L GTOET TT OSINHEAU S.CE
>> TOUNKHA Y, J.ON
HAI LI IVEN NEOME FNGLOOLWI
ME
ERMBS.
LLI WIE TAK M ONEESE ORQUONTI
TLR FOTIE I K ANDPEES TH OER
EUE Q T FUEORHESSIS DCUNIO
.IH
ANWE C G TBAO CKE TIO TL
T
AVWE HEETOE  KP TVIS HIMO.NG
MS.RIL MLE MU , ESYONVEHA A
OPY UNRTITE  MTOAKOMA C
N.
>>HA TNK YOU.
THIS QN STUEIOFRMECOS 4 AOM 2
ARYE MYITILARER VETANNT SHOPE
HI LTIENREE IFIN. V A.A
FALITYFT AERHIIS H S
WEPT
N WNDO IWARLWOD II.
D ANIA AV HE  WIEFRND
PEVEDELODOMAR CDIY PAYOTH
TR
RTDESETO S.RM
MYCE CON IS IS.
TH AE ERISRE TS NDMEOU
ALHH
CARE SGE -HEALTH CEAR
ORSH
GETA.
OWI KNE WRE A TOI GNGO BE TING
ONTHIL BL HT MATIGIALL AEV
TE
BTHATRE TUTHE ARESO PERELNN
GEORSHTAANS D SISCIPEAL
TSH
S.TAORGE
I ITINTHK VAS  IA IND LIPOTOT
INBRG UPD , ANK THI IN
WIS
NTME SNEIOD,SOINAYG HAONMEE AS
T NEBEFIESDOETOT N GHEHE TM THAL
RECA
GENL OY M  TTSHEAITEN BEF
S SO IERTHE ABIOS PSIANTYLI,
DUL WSIENE VIHA AON P
D-N
OAAPPR TCHO HCALTEAH ES ARECC
CTOR XI EOSXPED VSERETANWE AS SO
COOUEIN T DNEERETMIHE T
E IESCNCONTH WHEERHE TURXP EOS
S
EDEL RATO T O PANRGICSBLROEM
OR D?EAISSE
'ATTH'.S IT
>>HA T. YNKOU
LEM'S TO OVEN IT TLEO T- -
TTLTIED.WO
RFOHI TSSSIS DCUNION OLEITWO T
MR, .RA MUR A YY,OUREOG REC
D
TOEG B TINHESSIS DCUNIO
.
>>OO GD AONERFTNO
KTHANCHOU Y,  TRMAIANODO -
AICHANRMAN TAKON
HI TS
OPPOUNIT
WE AFI CREONHANTDE TTIT W
S
MANY PPLE G LLPUININ
THE
CTDIREE N,IO WNCACCOMTHISPLH
E
GO.AL
E THERISNGET GTITH --
E ES
ICDIFFORTYUL FGTTGEIN
AR C.
TAMILIVI SRYERCES IYMYN SONSOU
THWI TXPICOX E
UROSE.
FORESEC DAD, A ANDTHUNROD
E THRDBUENF  OHAOOPRF  PBES EN
T
V TONHE FERETANAD DORECESND A
ITPAFAS R E  TSTIM CHAE
ATTH
PRTHE ISESOCS INPD UAT
HOG W
UMPRE'IVPTE'ES ARAT UPDED- -
PTESPRUME'I'S ARE.NTRAED
WERE ARANC EOUDGEBO AUTINPD UAT
H
ESPRE OCHOANS D  TPEHETES RUL
ET SISOMENGHI WN RE A IOFVOFAR
BUARERTHE ERCOE NCNSBO A
UAM.
TADE TS ILINHE PROOTIL P
TOAV HE EEP NES
ATUNMMICNIOIT WHHE T.A V.PE O
N
RDIN OAC TERO EVHIE S.CEUCSS
INE THPOHEOFT  TAMRO PGRS I
O
HAUTERMM OHA WTKS WORND A WTHA
'ESDON'D T ANLLPEHOFUUCPRY ODAE
EATRO P
CTDU.
E THTEXTNE SRYISP  TG INTOD FIN
WHORKS
THE W HAORSUS PPDTEAN M
YPI
ESECFEG LONLAISTIND A
E
PAARE SRTOT OF LLR HEBI WTHS AT
H
ULK INWOTHGED T  JEOB DEON
GHRIT.
TETHE PO PAMROSSEN AENND IEPNTDE
SIMMCOISSI OONUT THE V...A
SEAV HE E  TENIMMED ANTI
N
THAT V..ARE SEC HRITAESEAV
ILEDO SOE E LVTHM OBPRLEDAN
ATTHEL B TF IEISREHEHO SDUL B
ANDEEPNDENY  BNTOD
TINHE
ESPROC
NTBE INAERL BL SREHRDOAS. T
MMA COTEN O C--N  ATIBIOMNA
F
IBOTHSES B
INOPPROSA TILINEOR F
ALFIOFCILI DLYECRNGNI O
ACINPTGS ICARI CTI
AU BEC
SEO
RAR FOO LG, SDITUESAV HE
WAOREDIT FIOEC DIS Y FNSORRSEA
VEILWHE  GRATENSK  SETICIEDAN D
MHTAV HE
DIF ORIFENGSNIPION
ON E TOWHEDU PNDROUL SCTHO
DLO
OK BCA WUTE EAGN REHA TTHE T
TRRCUEN P ICEROSSENBRS OKND A
OTESDO NP  HELNSTEVERA
NWED EETOO  DINMESOTHIXTOG  F
IT W ANDALARE E  THEL RE
ME
IT H
PEAPN.
RMCHAIAN TANAKO:NKHAOU Y, .MR
, RRMUAYRFOOU YRNTOM CME
.
A.V.UG SSTGES TSERO PPO
DTIMPN
OAAPPRTH TCHO ESU PRE
S OCPRESULWODDD A
OR ME
XIMPCOLETYO  TOCE THPRDS ESAN
HEFURTYDER LARSNS AWEET V
AS
SE.EK
THEY R WUEEQSTEIK STR
THE S
FRKEWAMORUT B.AHE T V
HA. S
DED LOVEPEEITHRWN O FRKMERAWO
FOSU PRESTIMPON.
ERTHOTISE  NNG TPREVTENS THI
OR TT  NHEEXCRETY FR
BY P RTIUTNGMEUIEQRES NTOFAW L
WETHURNSE EWORA FMEAI RRKEM
LA PCE FOR
FUTEOS EXP
E.
EDOESE RYVEON
REAGE?
,  NIFOTYWHOT N
ULI WOLID KE FACEEK
IST  ATH
POITONT  T TLEWO ATI PNDUT
NR
K EWAMORTOINAW L
>>ER AHESSHAONTI TTHT ISOU W
FY LAIT ITHURERS W
NGRO.E
TOPOC XIEXSRESU IOT NNGET GTI
T NEDO A TL ALSOLLS HIWIOT N
DEY
IT.
YOOTCAU NN SEL DAYNGETOMHI
T
OTIS NEI BNG DE.ON
ISTH POU WLDUTIN IT TO. LAW
TH PV.E A.TISUREMPCE PVERO IS
DIT.ERFFEN
ATWHHE TYID DRO IN OUINLLG AT
LOPITUTIT WHORI BININNGG
EVHENEYO A OADFIM TETS  INO
STE THBE
AY W.
WE WRELDOU PR FETOET BUGHT
IN FSOMAORT WEHE TN TO  DNO
WAEIME H AND GE AVTO.BAO CK
DOI OT NHI TWO WNKE LAD ULDEY
IT
TOAV HE O D SNGETOMHIKEO  TMA
PE SY.ED
ARCRSEETY MGHONCDOUAI SDRE THE
ISIVER PCEEL LEDEVF OL.EN DIA
ATHEYYI DREENUT ANGBO. 80%
ITSEA A R
TYLI.
WETOAV HE T ET G IRNTUEDRO AD.UN
EVWHATCA WERE NTO DO ET G
SOG THMEIN TONHEKS BOOAT, THS I
NWHATODSEE T H
PEAPN.
>>AP WE TEECPRIAHE T FET ACTH
A.V.S IOI D ANGOT PILAMRO PGRO T
VEHAME F ARA
RKWO.
WEVEEL BIERA FWOMERKS I
ARCENESSBUT LL H BE AVTO
E
CO IFIDIEDEVANN Y T.EN
RMCHAIAN TANAKO:EAO  GAH
.
.TLBUER
>>E H IAVENCOA MMRDRET GAGIN
IGR AIS IEET TAMP IORNTT THA W
O
OT N P BENITEFSND AHEA HLT
RE
T -  -BUINMESOTHS NEG ED
TE
E  DONATMEIMDIYELAU BEC
FIBENE N ATSRENG BOTEI GOENIV T
THER VETS.AN
ITHO ST D ULNOTH WBEHEHA WERE
H
RESOUESRCO TVI PROE  CDEAR
F
SE
ICRVE.
UL SITHOWHBED ,  IATSHE THT RIG
WAO  TE OVPRIDETHITEN BEF
Y
SEDEDAE RVTOMOANY D WA FVEOR
RD
INNS EURG,  TLII KE
ONENEVTITLN  ITIE I TTHAEPR
FIDOVESEP AOR RT ONHE WERTH
ASA.V. HHEOU RESESRC NRYESECSA
TOT MEE TDS NHEEEFND A ITOOT N,
PRREE IDA O RTPO TSSNGCOREN O
TATWH IS.
THATOW ALLE S FRK EWAMORR
V.T O  TGEETHOU RESESRCDEE NDE
ROTO PDEVI AL  FULUUNTCOINOFM
ALHETH CEAREN BTOITEFS ANET VER
U
HOWET  SDUL D NOTAYELT I
O T
E T PUONT NEBEFIS  OATDDHETHWI T
OT
TRMAIANANAKO:NK THAMROU Y,
.
BUER.
EEWE NDO  TVEMON. O
>> AS AREG RY TINK WTOOR
THISH UGTHI, EE NTOD W KNO
AT THE
EN SCIFITICND STA
S
CTHATS GRONES POUSHLD
IUTN
PLEACO T ESHABSTLIEWHE T N
PRNSPTUMIOF OOS EXPE.UR
AND TO N,HE DLIU YOBEEE EVTH
A.V.IL POTGR PROAML WIL
BLESTAE H ISTHPTESPRUMFNSIO O
EXSUPORE WLILASNC IRE
ENSPANAR ACYNDVEMP IROHE T
S OCPRESHATHWI WREWET  A
OG
NOWH  WITLOE THPIT P?GRROAM
>> TCI SCTIENFI
ARTA SNDD O
FAS
IOCISOAT NOT CONSAAUTI,
AINTI SCKGOI P.NT
SEREVID.ONA IT.G ABAE CK
REMORA TNCPANSREHO WY,E PEO. S
WE SAW, IT
AS W DLTFIIFCUO T
N PLEXAIASU PRETIMPVE P.CEROSS
DOHOW  WAIEXE PLNTO IT HE
MEO S ERWH D NDOOT ETHO ISRYVE
Y?DA
FTHEYKEL EELIARHE TY GGOE IN
AGTNS A ANDRIERDVSAALROCE.
WE WT THE ISPARA TNS
NCY
ANEASY TDEO RSNDNDTA AET G
NSTEVERAARHE T C NTHE EYD.EE
A IITEEGR W HWHH ATN BASEE
SAO SAR F BUT W TNEE ED
REHEVEMO TN UR BDEOFRO POFO
M
RAVETE.NS
ITMEOO TK  YEV SENORSEA TET M
SADILIBITYRO APPR D VEFO
XIC
SUEXPO.RE
L WITILAK TEEI -- TGHK TOOIX S
NCEREMGE TROY OMNPSRI O
TH ONDSASARDOF LL
D ANRIDUNGSE THORS YEA.
TH, E
LENODUN  IMYG  LONDUBDOLE I--N
MINY LGUNBL DOUSI IEDN ZEND A
W I ED SNGEECRNI
FOS R
ERCANC
NWE RD EETOR EMEMBEORATTH FLL A
OF V THES ERETANREATTH ANG DYI,
WE HMEE AVSOARHA TT
JUE ST
INFINDG T OUTVEY HEHA
EE BN
EXPOD ANWED  HTUE AVFU
REVETT
TRATENS NT HADOOTNO K
ILIT WBE TIRUT FE.UR
WETOAV HE ATOO LK  V THE
TM
RAVETENS W ANDTHA
THE
UMPRES AIOPTNSAU BREECRE TSEHE
ARRIMISILAESTIUT BEDE  WNEO T
ING IN P AF ELAN OS CTDOORTHWI
WOTHE D.RLHOP TNOUL PMO IGILOST
THSET N  DEMOWKED ANTAOO A LATK
F MESO OSEE THCAANS D D
IDEE
ATWHOPHE T TMPRE PSUWIONTIS
LG
O SHA TANWET  CTO SPEM R
THENUR BDEF ORO P.OF
THAI VEY BEO  MNOW L
YEAW,
AD, CAVOTELDIMECA AORIS,UT P
EVYTHIET TNGOGR HEINN A
ORWAZENID SUANY D ITBMTO IT
THN A.V. ITHPEHOS L WEYIL
APT.EOV I
S I WARTPA OETH B 20% 80%F
REUS AOT N GTIETNG THE
AR .
>> S C IANWHOOU Y 2TO 3SYE0 AR
WOHF OTSEP ROR
HA TT FHO TSEMRO
LFE THGU W TM OR--F GHEULAR
-
V.THE A. HAS NEREV
CEND[IIS]IBRNLE
ANDARHE TY ENEHE T O
WHS O
RACONTEDCTO TTH DO IESTE UD
D
E THERNDE ARHUF DSRE OIONDCOIT
I
T  TKEHANET BUNOF OM  THEVEHA
EEEREV BNDD AEDPRS  AA IVUMESPT
N
ER DETH
.A V.
AICHAKANRM TO:AN YHA TNK.OU
LEMR. O N,VI G
EAAHD.
>> YHA TNK C FOUORNGVEONNIHE T
ABUNRODT.LE
QMYN STUEIO P FISORRA MATUR
Y
D ANHNJOT.TU SAR
-- JON ST
AREWT.
ITMS SEEIO OBVUSHA TYOEVT ER
NA
S TOO THE TIG RHTBUNGHI,
O
ANDYBO WPA TTSO Y F.OR
ESATWH MGE DS ITD SEN T
R
ICSERVMEMBS ANDER VET
F
ISWE DHESSMI TEHOM CPR
SIEE
RMREFOE W NDEEAU BECTH OSEF
ECO
OBVITHSLOUY TRIE GH?HI TNG
ATWHU O  DYOINTHKHI TSS SAY
ABVAOUT R S ESLU AAN?AT NIO
>>HI TNKAYHE T PLLOR F AF O
ASISTH WUR ONE PLA TKEICT
ASEROVSE
THWH IATS  PAIFOR REE THCA
ANFIBED NE.TS
ERTHPLARE E FTYEN OPL PEOE WHO
EIE ISTHTRIR GHTOAN HD O D
WHATT ISHEND A TNO IRES
COIOERIDATN AUTBOHA WSTAT XE
WIEDE  BUST OR F IRS Y20EA
FR
OW N.
AN IIS CELPLOMET
YUN
ABCEACPT.LE
STE THCOF O WAR ISS. THI
ISTHS ICARI CTILTO  TPUET TOGRHE
THEOT TT  CALOSNG BOFEIEN  ITH
MI TO- - TAL THEOTOFOS CT
BEHEING  TARIL MIT
E  WCOE ARA THTRUNY ES LATOV
ITET V
ANERS.
SWE TPOUPRTHES RO TOPDANTE  WPU
ON FLAIN PS A WNDE SNDTA
EYD ANTHISET G D AUNCOTS
TDE
Y'N'
BUTRTHT E UE SRTPOHA OF NGVI
R THEIISCKBAS THHE WN D NEYEE I
N
TWHD ENE Y HEARNDCKSI ANG DYI
U
EE O  TTHE RVSEICEY GE TO
TH C ANTOURYY  TNDHEMECOAC BK
ED ANAR PER UUTNDCRUTY A
NR
TMAE DEO BFET EADE IANNDTS
NA
OUS SEABRTHT EI OLT HWNEA
H
.CARE
IS ACCE AABPTLEIS INDT HE T
HWELOSTGIANNGRU FA OITF
FUG ONTIINY.CISOET
MUCOF TSHI IS ST PEUR
SMMCOONSEEN I ANDOUWEF  C
LD
JUND SSTTAFOAC BK MEA R MO
NTOT
IDTSEHE TEA BURC RAUCTI
LLOF AF OS THI AP  SNDTONGINTHKI
ABTHT ERO PSSCEWO, I DUL
NGALCHLEY EVE ERSSNGCORE
NAL
ERLEAD INHI TS CO L,AL GOCKBA T
YO DTTRISIC A DNDIG0  A 1REAC
T PIDANUT P EGTHRYINTH IN
AT
PIBUANT D RNAN IT PUD T
IN
ZAHAMAOURDS S.RITEAL
SMTHE GUINOKG NTH IN E  CISAS
I
Y RATELLGOKSMIN GS.UN
RNBUHE TIT P 2S HO4 UR
DAA,
SEYSN VEDA AK. WEE
BUTET LL YROUST CONS,UEITNT
D'T W15RYOR,  FEA YRSMROOW N
L  WWEILE NVCOENA POELAN T
HEALUE ITHSSARYOS U EAV HEG INAR
ANILWED  WMAL KE G YOU AET
TWYLAERE PRO OV.IT
WEALAV HE OFL ISSEHE D
SES
D LINE.UP
OUGRO  ZNDERHA MINANASANTT W
U
RN
IT P.
THE A MENEN WNDOMATHO W SN I
ILATTH PEND D THRGHOUT I
SUFFEDHE TILAM SE S ESLNSEDAN
ESSEDIASE E  WAREISENG NOW
AV HERE CEDATGR PROSAMND AND A
ACTISDM AINBYRETED HE T
MEPADERT OF STICET  THA
E,CTFEIVTEAR TGELS DD,EAIT WHISF
TIEVPREN S AONNDY UTCRINDAN
HEARTHAL C
DOYOU EEOT N NEITOD  RTHENNVT
E
EEWHL.
HOWE STD ULNOAV HDEBLE INRS ON
HITO T TIDS EAIST HATHSSRO PCE
ANHE TSEIS D WSEEAS,E
NOAV HE
OW AENLLUS TEDO  PBUE RN
N
THE U..SCE SIN T0' 1HE97
'S.
ETTHE ALHAA S GOADREY NEOU THR
H
E LT ISOFE MM IUNSUISESND A
PU
YONLMARSS ID S UEANS.NCCAER
WHEARE WEA RTIY LLLI
TIGG
THISTHHE WN S SAOUNDOF VANS
H
VER EILINDDES PEEN  OTH
URGEIES  O--THNCURE GEOFY
URYOIO ACT?NS
T  TSOHA MISY TUGHT
>>NK THA
OU Y.
CHAIAN TANAKO:EDE  WNEVEO  TMO
.ON
WOI DUL A MR.REEE L AEA MNT
O
HEBE TCOAS LT TMM ON
IT E
TWO.
>>HA T. YNKOU
I THI TNKHEHI TPO TNGO TIN O
UN
ENEF RER TCEORE PONMPSUTIN O
FYCODID G INANG ITWAINRFO. V.A
YID ANSA.  VNG.ATOKETAS OG, LON
THARE E MAMY ANEX
ESPL.
T OKLO AENE THAGGEORT AN I
VIMNAET V
ANERS.
ITK  TOO AANCT OFESON CGR
SBE
V.USCAE  N DA.ID I GOTETT
DO
.NE
ASONYCE PROWA FSSORGO -RD- GIN
RWARMUSTE BPARA TNSNTRE A
H
E LDOU BEDDICOFIO  SWERE A
TEOTPRECDM  FROSTMIADNISTIRAON
WHWILLAKOT N TONACE TIEN  ITH
REFUTU
TRMAIANANAKO: TNKHA Y.OU
WE WVEL ILMON  OLE TTOIT III.
U K ANYOER FOTH
CU DIS
IO.
MRLE. MANNOU YRE A G
ONGOI T
LE OIII.IS DCU TN IOONLEIT
>> TNK
OU Y.
ETITLIIAB EST ASHLIES
PRN PTUMIOOFXPOSEURAL,
AN OWASSSON CCE
N IOOFON
EXPORE.
TH M.ANSEA V CWI. LL
CEOE
EXSSUPORE ATIIDS ENEDFI A
EDRMTEIN BYSE.A V. Y ETCRARNDDE
O
INUDCLEOU R0 LYGH 5ENFFDIER
T
NSTOXIND A7  1IEUNCOTRASS
DLARETERNO  TBUXPIT P E
UR.
THREE ESWEDYLR AEAIFDE INT
Y
THE S.ANRM AY V.D A. CLYREURNT
RE TIZGNESHEIN TOX
S.SO
BYAB ESTG SHLIINETH
SINCCOES OONFURXP EOS WE,E
E
REVIMONG TN UR BDEOFRO P
N
RAVETE.NS
O EYTH DVET NOHAO TVE PRO
HT
WTHEYPOE EREX.D SETO
CTHISIOCEONSSOFN URXP EOS
L
EDCONC TTHE ATREY HEWEHE TREND A
THATS  IWHHE TYEXER WE
SD
TO.
RIWT GHNO8% ARE DANIEEND
DTH
ISLD COUCHEL HP T GEAN I
BYCO
G EDNCINATTH,  YESEREYTH W
E
EX ASEPOD,WI INDT LLO ALS
V.IRQUE  TA.ORO PDEVIHE TRE
MEINL CAOPD N IOANANIFXA EM
THOTISE  NIC MEDAL
T-  -IFREHE
NISOTUF SCIENMEDILCA
ENEVID.CE
L'SAY E  HWEAVPTESPRUMEIV
ESSEDIASUT BER V AET O HANAS
NH
ISTHHEIL WL M  TLPHERET GEDI
CE
S  TSOHIUG AIS HPAE RT OTHE
LLBI
U ARNGGIE VIANET VERAS
NGGHFITINC CHAE, WHEERTH T
RE AIS PVEMPSUTIIS DLISEEA, ,STE
ID ANITVIRES MONGTA OBSESCLOR F
OEMTH TET GTHHA WT D  NEYEEDAN
O EYTH DT HA TO PVERO
SUEXPO.RE
AMI  DINAPISPO HD TETOATR EATH
TH CALHETHEARTLN  ITIHEI,E  T
OSPROPALLD WOULU EXC
TDEHE
RAVETETE LNSISR UND DETLTIE III,
E THOSDPOEXSERNO  TBUIT P
M
ETH FSTIR P GSIERAND F ULANSTPO
O119/ T N.OW
E THESTEE ARVEHONSRA WNYN  IMA
CAONNOS  LVER GEHAHE T
VE-YR ACNDSSCE AHEA HLT
E
SO I THI TNKTHAME A MMENDNT
S
THEK. MAR
ISTHNOIL WL HCAT TC E
ON,
GEONRANETINT EIR/1STPO 9
DOOT N WHI TNKSHOU PUTUR O
N GSEG IATTH B
KEAST.
FIAND ONLLNAY O OW H TRY PAFO I
DOWH, Y ETERS HA TVEO
PY
THFOR NR EIOW BEFIT
DOWHY VEE  WHAO TUT CROGRSAM
FOR ONEROUPF OET VTOANERS
Y
THFOR ER OISTH TRO GUPOET
BE?FINETS
DWEHANOO T CO TVEO WE UMEP
CHSE
TO.
S IT I-ISEA LFOSMPED RE.UL
CWENG CANHA
ITE .
WE DBENOO T THEVLIE  C TATHE
UH
LD ALY TRAVEO TE
NSBE
.FINETS
THKAN
OU Y.
RMCHAIAN TANAKO:NK THA
NTI WAO T GOTAITRGH
O  TY
TIQUES T FONORLEIT I.II
ENWHT IOM CESO TRO IMPNGVI
,T
THE.A VESST. ATSEHE T UF  O
R
ISRE PTUMARE.
ISHI TS AIDAL RFOSOEAN
NT
FYCODIE G INTH TE USOFMES HITI
?
W'DNUL'TWA WE  THENTENOFT
EUSML FIRY ESHABSTLI?ED
TIFREHES IDB FEE TK ACTOSHI
ESTIPL, .EA
>>DRO TADSESHA TTI , INTHK
EIHAR SEN POTALTI GNGOI
FORWD BUSITT  I C NOTE.PLOMET
IF WCODIFYTO IT O SN,OO V..A
GHMITAY SXPHE T EISUROSE NOT N I
EIRU O  SYOREWE NOS EOTXP.ED
WWE MT ANTOREE AKSU NE  WDO
OE
TOT HA TT P
NTOI.
FYCODIG INIT F NOW TORHEE,UT FUR
THS'E'G THNOINWIONWRG T. TTHHA
T BUNO DWEO TUS J TWAT NTO G
DOATHE T PTHATIT IF TS  INO
INITERIL,'ID DN'T H
PEAP.
CABE AE USWEW  KLLNOERTHERE A 6
YEOXOFS  TOS EICXPESUR
HAT
NWILLER SW
UP.
O WE DNTT NOWAO T LITIM VSERETAN
BYNGEL SONELOLY IL E.ER
AICHAKANRM TO:AN H IU.R EAYO
>>T WHA TISHET EFCTIV
EWA
TOY ER DETNEMI IFHO T
SEEX
TOSEPOD SOX TINT  APE S
C
TILOCA?ON
ATWHOULDERIHE T CRITEA
SET
>>ANKI MEME R,BE WVEHA
E
UGTHROHHIS UND DAN A
U.
THEE ERARLL STIE EO PPLVEO WHHA
BE EOSXPEDNANHA TIL
D,CA
,ODMBIAUAM.
REPOEXSUNOS  ISY WMONYUSHIT
SE
ICRVE.
IOPPELEIIHAN WAIG RHT NOWRE A
NGINDRKIAS G
INOLE.
RED ANWEVEOT N EINTAN LKTABG OU
ATTH
THISMES  IDOXPICST E AUROSE,
SWE
.LL
RYLIMITACEER SVI I WWHS AT
E
INLOOKRDTOG WA ANYSYS NOUSMO
EWITHURXPE.
>>DEUT OSIEF OTHIV IND
UAIL
ICSERVREMEMBEIN HAVTOMOG NI
RSN
MEASINGTHVE ERYEYG INTH
E ARINEABRTHDOANG D ERG INOV
ERTHE, IHE TREAYNOS  WULO  TTR
Y
KTRAC E THEE OSXPURNDSEDO A
ENPEEXRICE-  -REPOEXSUOS D
ESO
ONMEE. HAS
THA IATS BL PROEM E
LIARER
RAGENEFAONTIS D.CE
MEASTSEMURENEPO  TKECK TRAO S
EREFE THE VES. .ADO'N'HI T
H
E  WEYERD POEXSE TD ANITESAK
G  LSOONRFO T FM HETO GALINLY
R
ONDOU TIN SAYTHEYIGHT HEAV
KE, LIEV SENEA YER LRSAT
FR
RTDESETORMHEN ETH S DODTEN
TTT OULEOUS ERABICCHT EM
ALEXMT
ASUPORETH BNDY IM T
LEPEOPALER WE ADREY
IC SK.
TH THETRARY E O NGYI TTGE
AICLMSPPANVEROD D.AHE T VIS.
LOATINOKG LIHE TM RE TKEHEAS W
G THNOINERE.
LJU METE  SAYHIS.
I'T'M O NGYI TITRKWO WHVE E
E
HION TS TAN PELO UANERNDST
DTH
.AT
BU YWHT ATT  JOUUSS IDSA I
U
E,SERVOU YUT AALATOMICLY G
,
RDREGAF SSLE OYOERWHE U ARET, A
WHEROU Y WSEEXE PODO T.
THESHA CNG W THELEHOCE PRO
SF
WEHA WT RYRE A TGIN T OWOO RK
E
AU BREECSEAR WE E TTOINRYG
GEHIOM SETT  TNGHAASLLWI PINS
SSNGCORE
ATTH TEA MNSAVREHE HETOE  B
IDGU SINELESTH FETOR
MII TGHLYOT TAL WGR AEEU,H ITYO
BU TYITRNGOET GOR M AAJ
F
MYOL CS AGLEUETH DTOO SAE MES I
G ATBEINDEA AD HF SEOR I
DO
NOT ME UWIP THTE CRIA.RI
SATTH I S THED NDTAARASATTH H
ENBEHE T.RE
IS IIFT  TOI GNGBEO HA TIFT OU Y
EDJOIN M THEY,ITILARO NRAT MTE
WH, YOUATUT AOM GALICLY
E
BE, FINETSS ATTH IMESOTH
GE
CAN LK ATBUT OTDOI  N
NW
YOHOW  GWIU LLT TETHAGHHR TOU
.T
WHT J IUSLI OUTDNE I
SIBAEVLLCAY YONEEVER,HEYWRE
ATES TLLIM
BUREWET  ARYIN TITGEO T
FODSERE WHE NT  IISTHDEEED
EO
.ST
BUTNK FRAER, LYTHOTARE E RHE
THE GSIN WT E ARNOG LKTAIN
.
AWE FOCINGBU ON RN
S  PITDAN
ATOSTHE NSEA WPOPS DUM
ATWH A INGTRM YIO IDTIFYS I
HIATTH TISS  A PVEVAERSIEMRO PBL
TH THOUGUTHE MITARYO S WLE
ITEE SMSDVER ARISAAL, V.T A.
T
SHOTLDOU N
BE.
HOIT SDUL BAE  GENIFHA TT
SOEON CN ESOM IDANS, SAY
S
D,POEXSEEPHE T R Y ILYS,
T
YOUER W
KI LOOTH ANGT ONNAE TI
OFEMADY CECI SENIESTS UDINS AC
THICWHH EYAY SWE, TAN CNOARA DW
CO ASILUONXPUTBO EUROSE T
S PRNIT ADI CNDONWEONTIS RE ABU
NGSEEIEV, ENN IT WHIUDE THSTSIE
HEATWH TREAL SAY HS  IWEEAV
INIEFFSUICA. DNTAT
T A LO P TOFHEBLROEMS IGOEN PTA
T
O OD D DVET NOHAHE T
SUNTICFFIEAT DA T AND - PHEOT
TITHD E  P HMEAS
SEASD.-N
ISOE THS ERNO WAYSO --
HE
IS NWAY AT CTOREAE TOH COR
UDSTY.
9WITH1 WE GTU FOTORNTENA I
TTHATHE.A V.AD HOR C AOHYSTT UD
THAD HDOEE BN GIN POORRI T
9/ SO ADEYTH H AFE PER
F UPNE OTEE THDAF OOS EXPEURLI
PRSVEUSA.-DREAT
PBYN'TAENGOO'S N ASIONTHE
DAHE TYE HAV IFFINS SU
IT
ANWILL NE EREV BIEFFSUIC.NT
T  WSOHA D AWERENGOISDI HOL
G
UP T HEAREH LTCAND A BSEFENIT
FONSTEVERA OAS BEDNAT D
T
PETHE  HAGNTON B NASOTLEN EEAB
TO.VIRODE
ANIT WVEL ILNEGER T B
TE.
SO IHINKISHA TT
C THE2CHAT-2
WEEAVLA PE D CETHNSTEVERAN. I
BECAW E USNOREEYTH AOR F
DO
GO AVE PNDRO OHE TIRE. CWNAS
EVYO IENF EDSMU OK0 OR F 2
S
YOAND  GOT LNCG UNCA A AERND
ORDOCTEDND A MOAALIC BED TRDRI
TO MUE AKYO PHAVERO T LYOT URGUN
NCCAE  CERAMOMFRNGMO SKI
,SO
COONMEE WAD ULALE  CYSOM
D
YSAY,ED LOUIVE N  ITHNDTYCI A
BRTHEAEDG. SMO
HWE SE AVTOIVRTTA L TG INBY
F DECO OETH W.A V.,S CHHI IETHHE
N TEVERAHETSGE TITEN BEFEF  OTH
DO
S IT ITNOTIAU CSA I, ONIT
NT
EVENOR CONLARETI
ISOHI TT  TNKHA I TISHEEUESS W
GEINTOS AE WRY TFIO  TDENE I
H WHIC WISHY AT  TLLHASOE THES''
ARINTAE LKTABG OUSU PRE
TIN
G BEINE E THONTHINTHG UL SATHO
I
FTURHE T B PN DEOF
OFRO.
USBECADATHE E S  DTAOETNO
TUACALLY.XI EST
AICHAKANRM TO:ANNK THA Y.OU
ON. MRDRE,CK QUI.LY
>> TNKHA. YOU
I THINTHK EER VETS  GANETETH
BEFINETTHIT HS  ONAE IL
THNE
, HEAD SD ENOF
RYTO.
THU K ANYOCLR FOINTHINUDG
IOUMESPT I ANSCTTHN E BLILO TR
MOPRHI TS ESOCSWA FOR.RD
PSOMENTS  BUSESINS,E W
TWAALYSREK OOCARF  OOUEO PE
AND S IITTH ON MI CISOMEETT A
TEE THVEPPNSRA ATIPRROIASON
TEMMCOITE WHE ERSISTH I.OI GNG
WEWNO H C ICIRUALOIST  T
TAOFAR CE UR O PEOE.PL
OPR OUPELEURRE A OANET VER
S.SO
E L IOV -ULI - WO TLOD VE
M FARROR. M SWATERT O
THNE
NHUMAOFOS CT ETOT N GHENGTI T
LEIOSLGIAT.DON NE
ITHATCOTHS E .ST
ERY Y THEERS IHE T
UM N
OCOSTNOT TTINONITG  D
D SY,ONECDL
MS  I18
THONSN
GHENOUFOIM TE V.THR E A.O T
OTWE GID C AOVNEAC VCINDS. LES
WECAN  IO  DITN LS?ES
K THI INWED.HO SUL
LIATARS E  ETA SKEAYRYVE D
AS ANAAT NIOLEC SISITURY E.SUTT
OUENWH YOWEE S HYAS EILNG THI
SO
GHHR TOUHEND A TON MEYEI B
IENSPT,HINK
V OURS ERETANEDNE
TO KW THN  WATHEEYTHE COM
HO WTH, EYT L ILNOBE
DI
D.ARSCDE
E ONN TEVERARVO WHSEEDN IQRA
DANNIFG AHAAIANST STOD FE, M I
ANRHE CNTOURY D WASO NGOI TROU
NSTEVERA W AT HAWENG DREOI T
OOU
RAVER TE W, NSWEE LDOU B
ATWA
IITS AINHI CLLEMSTG ATOMT ENFR
SOO E ONWHTS BISOOEN  OTH
NDGROUND AFG AANNIHAST
G YOA UNO N MAWHENS HASE
T
OF CUELEOLAGSIGES T  D ACKND
IN
AD ER GOVTHENNMT AT SMSEE
, TIACVENGCAUNRIAND
NGMOUNVI
FAS AARS A THEOFUNMOT FOIM TE
R
IMTAEMPLENTHONTI, ATUL SHOBED
TIE THENVE CREONN ATRSIO
RE.
BE, W HODOE WMP IESHIOAMELENTU
CLRSFIT-SASIC TOXURXP EOS
ARTHAL CPRANE D ONENEVTIND AE
BETS F THO H WSEHOEAV
RVSE?ED
D ENOF SVEURY -OFEN- D .TO SRY
S CWEANY PLIMIFF ISTH IWE
T
OKEEPS  EURYE TONHERAR LGE
RGSEINNTEA WONSTLA BCKAI SD
A
TBHEARGAKREIN W I, AYITTOO
FTEORE MUT BGO A IM G TO
TD ENMYE IMON
AR ETH
CAADVOORNGTI FER OTHSO TT
HWHATD PEAPNETODO ME
NET
ENHAPPO T MBROTRS A
NDSIT Y
ANERSTS DO  S MENWH I
MARI , ANN CASTD.PRD OU
ANJUST L AWHTLITE O,E ILAGE H
SSPAEDY. AWA
WE AIN LREOSBATHG E ORLETT FHE T
ARHE M ATSNDF DSIN ONR OUOW
VENRANIOM CMU.TY
ITS INA UBLEPCCTAE F A C
Y
SPWHO KSEAGHO  SHILYF  O
EIR
RAVETEUNCON MMDY ITANRTUR PPO
SO
THOV LE  SEMO
UC MH.
D A'REHE'E S THPAAZCRY .RT
SO IITS BL DOA
S ITD  IHI WSOITEA RCHH WIT
INN NTTEIOLLD ANCOIOORABAT
IATSHA WISIST  M
NGSI..TH
E THA.V. SULHODRASEE PAM FTERO
THSSRO PCE
THBUT E VOU. .ASHLD BG DOE IN
O
ONGMI TGR COND S ESAN,YISANG
REREHE AEAHE T WSSPK OTRN  IOU
HEE  CTHAR ASTSYEME  HNDER
IO
HIWEW  T WNKE B CAN ISTOLER
REREHE AESHE T R WRCOUES
ND
OTO DT. I
T'L' FMOS VEWAORRDET TOGR.HE
ANIT CNEE  BDO
.CH TRMAIANANAKOY
MORER OM M OREE ONMOLAOR AD D.
WEEE ND TTTRO USER VURETS.AN
EYTHRUST US HEENWH T
WT
ARTO WS.OR F U
YOANTHK
AICHANRM TANAKO:HA T. YNKOU
IYOEL TL FRU OM MYER P
NL
RIEXPEI CEEN, T  PAMAROF T
HEBU
RN C PITTYMUOMNI
VEI LIIND RA IQND AL  F IEEKELI
TAMI  A TKIICNGEIMB. BOM
AHAI VE SEALRDYNEEDSRI FENHO W
RAVEHA BCE CINANR AE RNDAR
CAS.ER
REWE AETLL A GNGTI I
ELI FECA SERD REEVYIM T.
I O
A FOR EIECCHK ATT GHTHET SOMNGHI
CK C AHET  TUPHAINMESOTH
L
OUBE F.ND
NENO OOL TD MHIANE YTNG W
NI
NTT GOSEAQO  TIRN  I
0520.
TOWAI S T, LDGEN  OALA P
D
ANDLLE  WWICAAK TE YO OREF OU Y
UWH
C YENOUEOM HE.OM
THNT CISOUE  GRYAVTAA X T CUT
OH
ESTIC RHEE EO PPLS TINHI
COY.TR
SOF  IEU YOAR WRIDENG T HOW
O
PAY FORS, THIONHY W 'OU Y
REK  LLYOOSE TATHOAX T CSUT
.
E THER PLEY OF.ON MEY
ERE S PLF TYEN OFONEMOY USR
ENWHTE  WCU TAXER UND
TRU,MP
OBDEUNR A,AM GND UERBURGEOE
SH
JR.,ND A IHE TRETYPLS ENF O
TONEMOY AK TEOFAR CE ET V
AS
WA IIFT RIPRS IO
ZETID.
I O NTWA TINPOT W, UTWEDL ILEN
UPT NGOI I.YWANAY
'ITT'S  TSAE MEHANGHI T
THA
WENPPEDENH ITAGNG OTRA
BUNDWET  E UEDPAK TGINOFAR CE
PETH ALET OFENE D HEIV L
EH
WA IENT  EMOS REVEENXPSI
.
WIFITDIE D N OROHE T FNT
N,
OUWE CCH CLDATISHE T DARSEEA E
N
GEMAD NAT. I
E CABEUS TINHECOND E,  IRENGSS
O
GG INTOE IN
ITBUT IG MHTFI BE RS YVEEA
M
NOITANW D ENIL WL OSUPD  CNGTI
REMO
NAK MESO SSEEN.
IFSEE EMO  TBEBL AORTOE  BWRO
R TACUTSANWE,  CW OR BRORFO
.THIS
TH
YOK U.
RMCHAIAN TANAKO:NK THA
OU Y.
E ONNAFIL W TD ORONSHILE TIT
.
>>OO GDFT A.NOERON
THGIONS GR FEFATULOR
R
COMMMENT.
I  AAMEGISTIVEIASS AOC
T
ERE THAMANICEGIO
I ANDDER SVE
AS A MINAREM FRO 20020TW5 O .10
I HAVESSIT WNEN BEDURIT PS
IN
ECLOSXI PROO TYMI TTHERWHE
E
OOTRPS ALE SPTND AIV LED
ND
.UGFOHT
NTREE CEGEAS PSA OBLTHF E
UA
VYR TENAASCT A W A ROFULEST
YES OF AY OCDVACDANE CAM
DETES DEAFSUEXR PO FORHE
VE
RATEN.
NSTEVERAOMRE A CGINOM H
WIH
SELNILESS ADI CNDONCAONTIS EDUS
BYIN TOX
THA IATS  FT.AC
AVWE HCTTOE  A N.OW
EEWE KP TKIALNGBO A TUTHETSOS.
ER OKETHS NAI SD,ASONO E D
ABTHT ET  COSE ENWH WDARSTTE
THR.WA
HIT TASOUNE  BCO PD TEAS
F
COTHE WA OSTF
E.A VTOHA. S ACE  BREY.ONTIAR
THEY HT E AVNO BWAALYS TN EEAT
E
REFOONT.
EYTH WT FOAINER CTARUM NBE
OFER VET PS ANTOSASWA AFROM
AICERTSUEXN PO W ARENDEN HETH
NUERMB REAES AINER CTAT,MO AUN
THCTAY M A
--HEN EYTHCT A
TH AREEIOT N BNGRO P.TIACVE
WEAND TOOP HE  WTHGEERPACAE N
H
IS CENPROMEHEGVESI LONLAISTI
THIL WL AOOWLL T ESHABSTLI
PRNSPTUMIOF OURXP EOSE B
YCR
TIEANG A FRKMERAWOOR F
ARANTRSPHECYEN T.  V.ANCA USEO T
ISTAESBLTIADH DIREALON PVEMPSUTI
ILINSEESS UTHE T FE.UR
NO CWEAN LKET EPTIISEGLA
E
ILLNS AT A
IM TE.
THU.K ANYO
RMCHAIAN TANAKO: IVEL ILMON O
THETIEX NT E.TL
ITBEIL WL ED LY ORHE TNGPE ONI
TOFHE DIOCUISSSWIN LLLE BE D
Y
MS.CH ROA
.
--IR B.CH
>>NK THA
OU Y.
IAV HAE IC TOX EOSUR
EDI
TYBISALI
ISTHSSUES VEOR IRYMPONTTA T
.ME
ESU PRETIMPON
IIE PCEESNOS  L
S
CRITHAALIC TTHN E
TH OER
ONCOMP
TSEN.
THTS LISIFHE TDE BURHEONN  T
VEOMN RAFRNGRO PVI
HE TIR
ESILLN
PTESPRUMELNSIO H
WIP TH
ENPREVTITAVEAR CETH IN
IAT
BLESTAHEISSR ET BTETAEVPRENVETI
NDRECA AHA WTRSOC DTOOOAN C L
KO
CH WR,HI HATPSEL CBL PCHROSEM
TINHEAR ELY S NGETAS,Y OOTNL
TH SA INAVG UTFELI BGAV SIN
MOHEINY  TON LG. RUN
WATHE OTISR  NONUS JT HE
BAD.FILEEL
IMESTHE WICTPAS OM BLLECMORE
SIVIEBLMES  ATIS  GOE I, ONAS
TA
EVFOS R YERER OTH. WAR
TH AE ERISAT B BE TLTOHTFOE UG
ETOURNSE TOST HATH
WHE O
VORENTLUEEERTOD  SVE C THE
Y
TAARE REN KECAO F, O N TTTMAER
O
.ST
S  PITUTTEE THVE TN RAAT
HEFO
T.FRREON
WEBLE ERA KANHE COU TCKO
RNA
ONTI.
AWE A NREOTFOINSKG RHE T S
EN
N,ET RURUT BWHNL OY OW IATS
O
S, U CR E ARFOJUE THINESRI
STSUWHNEAID E ILINCEER SVI
,VI
BLSIE A ILEISNVIB
TTIE MEACO T IOW NOR TTH
CU OKEF ANENRRT D F
URUTEA
RAVETE.NS
COSTOTAS W N AVE DRIR
HE WN
RECONG T ASSNDTE WHEHI
OU E
TWENT WOARO  SHOEYTH STD ULNO
SH AWAPAFOY R HANGYI W
WATS
IN.RRCUED
RMCHAIAN TANAKO: YHA TNK,OU M
.
RCBU
MB. MRLAR.ND A M LOUE,IS YRE A
QFT AIN -ER-
UE QUEFT AERE. M
FMYSTIR QNSTUEIOMELE, T
PREAC
IT.
ETH VES. .ADOUPOT N SURRTPO O
AGGEORT AN PTISUREMP,
ATSTEG INTH EANSIS AR
EIN
TENSCOISNTIT WH D.OD
TOSE T P HSERENTREE ERAGE
H WIT
THSMSS AES
EN
>>O. N
THENEVE IDCEEC RDSOR I SWHA T
E TIE TLOWSHEDALEV SER
GT
GEORANXP ESSILOONSUEX- POS.RE
NO DWEO E AGT RETH V.,.A
.THEIER
CHAKANRM TO:AN TOUNKHA Y
MRSAI W N BR. OWHIAKSHE .HES AD
>>CTOR CRE
EAR PE ERTN WITRKWO WINH
YZANALGIG INLEN,ATSLIOE W
STNGROLYEE AGRUPND A SHERTPO T
EXN NSPAIOER CTOOVET VANERS I
NH
TI SATEC OONF TSHI
ATGILESLN.IO
AICHAKANRM TO:ANHA T. YNKOU
AD AGOHEINRA, NKERMEG MB
O.
>>OW HAN C.AHE T V.DXP EAN
SEREN CHAR OETH HEFLTEAH
CS
OF BNXPIT P E
UROSE?
E DO WSTJU AICOMUTATUTLYAL P
INHE TLE TIT AHE TSEN TNDHE
DOSAY XPOT N ED ANITMO ANY?RE
AORST WREE LILOO L
NGKI?
E AS WTOIETRD ET GS  THI,SSPAED
WEEAVMA TO KEWEUR SE
AV E
SWANSERND AT  JUSG ITWRINAHE C
ISAYBEOMETNGHIE
W
GHMIT
REAGONE  TNES HIPAL,UT BVEE  WHA
TOTH IETT EVUGROH YYBEROD EE
AICHAKANRM TO:ANHO ENTE LSWA
O
NTOM CME
>>. V.A CANEP ACCNCSCT IE
ENCDE.
THIDTSE REIVIWN O E
S IT IENEVENRI WTTFO IN AN AURSI
GEORAN EEOSXPUR AINER CTA
ILSESLNSE
.
SO L AKIOONGR OTT HE IACPLESAS
RSFIT REPE ATSTND AHE TNDI FIN
G
WAY TDOO OM SRECOE MPENSHEIV
SEEXPOESOD  W A CANW W
EEIF NYOD DEBET  WNDHAE. HWEAV
A.E THV.DYLR AEAHEAS H T
AUTOITORY OUOO LK THIDTSE
ENA
ONALDE ACAMI, USEYTH J
TNE
EX TEDO  ICIERSE
AIRM TAKO:AN
MS.S,OR TRE
A
CYOW URMEOMNT ITHE ATCH
THOUABT 9/E 11 BOD MEL
NGEA
GOOD MO ELOD TT.OKLO A
I NTORI CLA, FYIN ANITDDIO
TOUAERTH QTIFILICATS,ON I
APULWOD NCY PLCO TSIESON
O
RBAIAZNEOR HNDDSAR ACC A
SO
THHEALAR CE BEDASN OIOOC LAT.NS
DOON AESNY WELE SET ANTOEF BRI
Y
SPRE RD ONTO MKIANNGBEEMROS B
IIFYOEA HR ECCOU RROUY,TL YRE A
NENCCOERD TTHABEAYSE THE
ESNSPTUMIOITRE A WUT RME
EAOR RNSOND ARARB AIT.RY
OTDOI  NHINKHAT  TISHEAS C
>
IOTID D NITEA MN HA TTAY W
.
ASBUT E W M AREINOVG F, WAORRD
ETHT ESN, DOWHEND A T
WHT
STANRD WFOUSE E REA RESH?RC
E IF WTE ARNOOI GNG D
THNE
TPATHTOT HAAULLTIMACAYHE WN
ENROEDST F OHEM REYOOUN T
UWE
REOV CEDER
A ANDGUMSSIN
YOEVEREX INES  WSEPOD,THA
IAITCRERO  DWE
SE U?
DOHOW COE  WENAGE E V.
O
USET? I
WETO  DNO W GT ANTO TDOO WN
HEA
THBL OF  WAT NAVGEORY  A
T
ANOR.GE
IISAGE TH IATTES SAVONEY
IOI DNGIEEAT RL
THWIWALU BE RTEITAV NY  WLDN'T
HA MAV SEDECEYON BHESEAU T
YWA
EDITNTILWO TS HI TRDM TOFHE
DIFF OOVO  TPREE IDTH BEN
.
THNO IATS WATHT E ANWEY  WTOT
DO IT,HE EIT
TRMAIANANAKO:K, O MT, BR.OS
IF EEOOMNEULE LSCOECHD IM
,
WHATAL R IECHEISL  TOS M
VALENTES RRYRAPITOSSLL INEES
MOHAD SU PRERES.TIMPON
TH CRAE RECEANRS BHESEAU T
YAR
ARAE REPE HNDAPNNGNI IY VER
YOGEEO PPL
,ARHE TY ASNOE T
ALPREVT ENBYIN DEF
IOITN.
NTI WAVEO  TMO OR.TON  MB. LAM
GO.HE AAD
>> TOUNKHA Y
ONTWA T SAY ONE TASNGHI B
N
RIEXPENCEEN IS  THITEMMCOITE A
SWA HOUINOPG ESWIR TNSM FRO
TH V..A CESLDOU R
NDPO.
ESREI PRLAT ENA APE RGCHRTE O
VIMET VINANERS CAME ARIND A
CUFOSAG ON TENRA OE.NG
WAI SEDHO SCKWEHA TT TIRE A S
ONGYI TST ELIABSH
MPRE PSU
S
AL0 STMO 6AFARYES POR TEEXRESU
CE PTOLA
TH 9POE STTE1 /1VENMU COMTYNI
ASATTH HRO GWN AEP REDSERENT
ONSHIL, CALUS JT
E  LIK
HER
RAVETENSUP GRO N AS,REOIEREV G
O
UPIV GE ISN  OTH.SS IUE
I NT TMAO KEUR SEVE E
ONRE
RSUNDENDTAST, THAHO TSE W
ICEDRNON CCET ABS OUNDSTCO AO
.PACE
EVEENEYO KPS FG HTIGINR
THEPL PEOE, AE  SNDOMVE
PAY  AEDWAATD ANTHIL WL
AE
R OTHE FOPPELEHTIGAR HR.
ITILL
AK MEHE CMUNIK WTYOR
HA H AERNDTODEARR AB ESTSHLI
PTESPRUM
NSIO.
TH N AEYREIN GOTIVG UP.
SOS  THISISCDIUSONUT ABO H
D
AWHEN TNDHE PEAC, 'I'TTA S LI
C
.EMADIC
IITENHAS PPG.IN
ERE THAMUBANIC PPPC LISUTSORT. I
TUEVENTHLYAL, EY I GOT
FOT R
T AGEN.ANORGE
ITAK MES TEN SSEINACO T HE T
OLWHOSPUE RP POFE  ATISUREMP
ON
ISIN SAY TTHG ATASREHE WSHI
TYXITOCI ATI INDT TH TESO
E
N.TEVERA
MRWN BRO, IT O  DNOFOWKN I
AN E HNEASNER VEDO ATU SDYR O
A IOULLCATOF A THA
WAS
ILOSTTHN EIM TEHE TAMIE VTN
VENS WE W FTIAING
TSNEBEFIOR FTEYP HERANIONSN
OITHPOYRDND AIFHE T D
RET
THOUGSIN YHAAV HE DFI TO TGH
LAR,FO BERDD C
CEANR.
T BU C YIFOUILLDOU FN USL  I
COMMUNTEITE NDRSDETASTHOS W IDUP
IT TS  ITORYO  TNCPUHHI T
N
THELD FIE
>> C THET OSOF, TIAING
WO
PUYOU STA T CON  OA
IF LE?
SOWHONMEE EDSEO RVHIS UNTR
S
IA DNE FMRO RARCANCROS,ER F
REPOEXSU TTHS ATREY HEWEEDXP EOS
TO UERND DENLOEPYM
DO NW  KOTNOU W HOYOCOT PUA
N
AFOIF LE RE EO PPLHEATTH T
GOMERNNTINEN ST M' HTOA'SAY W
RT STOTAIT W
NNI CAOTIN BEGUN TO NDRSDETA
THPTON CCE OEETOR  SOW HOU Y
CALYOPPRER CUT P A AT OSON
NIN
ALVIDIDU''
IF LE.
WHAN IAT CEL TLOU YS I TTHA
FOA.V., THR E PTASAR5  1YE
N R EIOWCHSEREARAS H
HO N
IFSIGNINANICT EASE IN
SIRTPEENON ANGMOBI HERDECI
DPOEXSEET V EANERS,NVEIV GGIN
ISE THEXRANGTI F FWOMERK
OR
NGADDIHO TSE PTISUREMPON
ITCONDANNSIO,  FTHD EYTOLEAID
DO
ISTHHO SRVD ULSE PASE  ALEROWFU
CANAIORYAL TE TOPTHO E SNEPONT
FORE CAINATG
NEW
SIONE-S--FZEITLALME FRA
RKW.
LITV.VEEAS TH IA.N ERDRE IV''
ATSE
INLEHI TS IOSLGIAT WN,E
>> TOUNKHA YROR. M B.WN
D WOI ULOKELI TNK THI- - T
VITEM NAVEF NSRA OAERAMIC
CH MR TEINA. AYRE
DR.IS LO' IA,'MEUR' YOU
'VE
D ASKEON TSHI.OP TIC
>>NKHI M YOUR. CN,IRHAMA
K
U YO T ATOLLER VHEETTS ANOU
TH
TOSTOU YR EANGRO LP.RSDEHI
ISTHS AN INTORMPTAIT TLE WE
DI TEDO
USSCS.
THISS ACHESSRO TOFOU SL HE T
LLBI.
S IT IONSEBAD  A BILL TUT HAYO
ALRKWOEDHEOG TETROTOR  P
.
IITPRTHS E IVUMESPTEEN B
IS
FORANET VERSEEXS PODNSTOO XI
BT,AC ASAARIPTICAA N BI
RAL
BIT TLLHA OTEGIRINA OFRD OM
URE
RATENMU COM.TINIES
AWEIN MREOVITG  FWAORRDSIT,  I
NOTLTIE TV  IOFPOS HIIM
AT
.BILL
IITTHS E SE OLOFON HINORG -
L VIE TATHGAORN ATPS KEE TSHI-TH
T TIPAENINIVALE  TRD OEROENS EUR
T GWEETE  CHEARDANEF BENSIT
HEATTH T VSERETANEE ND
R THD EIDDOWIWEESPO SUS.AN
WO
REARE ONINLYG
HI TS.
ITTH IS T HEE ARDDATTH A
SS
FATHE S LYMI ALL.
WJUI STT ANTO RSOIEEVW
OF
THEXC E'ESUS I 'VEARN EEHEGIN
ER A OR.VE
T,FIRSAAI WT UT MINNE WE,E
O
DO ME RE OARSECHN TTHA
.
S  GITOECKBAO  TIGE THORALIN
SEEXCU'HE TREN'S ENOU I O
FH
.BIE NS
I'D  SVEAINDEROV A O
NGIFARYIMIHI TS MANFSIORR,CL
.
E THER ENOH EE DEVINC
TO
ESSUGGTHT ATOX TIC CMO SKE
AN
ODPREUCNE ILLES ITHEUNGS
UNMMET
ASDISE.ES
RCCAS OGINENCAUSCAE
ERNC.
TOE SMC OKNSNTCOAIR.AN CCE
'THE'VEIFDE INTRCD IECASOGINEN
INHEOI SL,
OS EXPEDANET VER
SDE
LOVEPAN CT R,CE IY VISER
STRWHTIGFOD.AR
'ERTHE'SUG ENOH EEDEVINC
EXINOLAPATFRG OMIR FERIGEFHT
H
WEO REXP EO EDOS TTJEUE F
E THERUG EISNOHVI ENCDEEN  IROU
S.N OWU.ONNV EIRNTMEALRCES REAH
ATTHNTRE PVES BUS RNEIOMFR B
NG
UCCONDDTEN  IROUAC B OARKYDS
RI.
ESSTDURIE N  ITH SITUNED
THERISUG ENOENEVH IDH  WCEIT
I
UG EGHNOHUS SCION TEST HATH
R
INCAE USE THG ESS.USON I
DO' THAT VEGOO EY BED ONTH
SC PIFNTIC
ERAPS.
WEUSAN C JENLIT STRO  TOU
RAVENSURND A OANET VER''
WDOWIWSHOREVEUT O OOVANR D
AIAGNHO WHEAY S T NHAY VEROTO HE
TH AEYREUTBS AOLALY ELHEY.TH
EYW NOTHYIRE A D ONGRD  DEAOMFR
THROTE HE EHAUSXCE SEE BNIS, TH
WILLE  BCHO TOMUSTF  OA ORINRA F
THUTSTINITN.IO
E THESFUE ARUNED MDATE
D
DWE'O' HKNT OW
TOWHE
STINNSUTITIOOIRE A GHA TNGO LEND
.IT
SIT IUR O RIBPOESNSITILY.
WEDOUS MT FOHA TT
OUR R
RAVETE.NS
ATTH IONTUTITIRGUMT IS
FRIDND IIVHOLSUA WHEUT P T
INIOITSTUTT.FIN RS
TI AMLIELNGWEOU Y, PUUS MT
T
ROU VS ERETAN
RSFIT.
WEUS M OGIT VEURER VETSANE, TH
VENTN RACEDC RIANANET VER
SEFOCU
MUS CTAT KE OE AROF
URVE
RATENSE LIK OURENME ERG
CYDE
NTRTPAME
OTTHE CUR HEEXCO ISET OS STTO
MU
ITHATLUA S VAEMSTE ATT.EN
'DOI N'OWT KNBO AUTOU YALMY,  V
S
TO  TPUPL PEOT.FIE RS
VEOUR  ARATENSIN TREAK OCAG RE
AL VUE I OTENSADINGEF TT
X
BRO KSEA TNEE THTUILOFS  M
S
ANDONIL MLIS
O IS THEVEGI TANET VERTHS EAR C
H
Y TATHEEE ND, E CABEUSEYTH
T EDNE IGHRIT N.OW
THR OTE HES CUEXSEAT T PAC
S
OO T FT.AS
ISTHS IIC RID
OUULS.
ASHE TS ID WOWOFUR OER VETSAN,
AR WIFE NGMOE VIASOO T F
K FOSE  LIKANBRLIE RSOTD HE.
WHFFE ARSUINERG FMRO
COTITRNSICVE BROITHINCOLO, ISWH
E ARYGOXENEP D ADEENNTNDBL UNA
O
FOAR CE RTHR EIY,AM FILR O
.HEOTRS
AR WIFE NGMOE VIASOO T F
PATHE  ICESASOO T FT  WT,HAEYTH
ARE ARHEG INISHA T WTHT EY
O
UNLADEY LTI DD.EA
STJUWHIK LE ATNEAP HPE
WHDN
TAGENNG OEND AIERE A VAMTN
NSTEVERA
NCSIE IARN EEHEOUG INAB
S
GIA BEINNNGL- REAME FDBAC
KR
V TOMHES ERETAN
MINY
RIDIST.CT
RAVEA TEERANN SWALHE T CTOL
, DUTYSEILWHE ININRVG OUTH
IR,BR HE DITHEAE 'D' TTAT LK
E
MEFUTI PS,ARLACUR MANTEATR
D
CAENINRCOG
HEOTTAMIR LIMS IRYTEWEHA TT
RI
OSEDF. O
WHTUE  HREEDRNE, HOME H
D TINOCESHIHIRE BATTH INGN
E
HAMEFUS D CA SEAUD NLLTO O
S
.BODY
HEAS LERATIA DOSGNEDH  WIT
AG
ESSI FORESOFM  TRCUTILA
CA.ER
E SPDEITCTS HID'ATORE'S B
IF
THATORDO- CTE'SEL BFIET THA
TH LOU WLD AD EATO, LA CIME
IE DV8ENCLHID S M.AI
I NEVEHA O MEL TLSE
HER
-HUSND ISLL STIAVIN
GCO
TANSNT CG,GHOUINICHR CON
COLLNGHI I ASSNEESERFTNG BEI
DEN EDOY IDDE THMIT. ELEAS
.MSUR BVE, KEHAEAOU Y HRD F
ERMBSURF  OYOIZRG OAN
IOAN
THE  HATAVIAENBE D WOSGNEDHIT
TNCCAEREIT HATHTO DROC
LIBEEEVAS WUE DPOO  TEXANRESU,
CLEITHR ERMSAI WEDDEE NIEY  BTHD
V8
-- V.?.A
Y>> WESE HHORDEA T OANUSDS
FTH
S SAOUNDOFER VETSANEI, TH
ETERAY VGEANERS INTTGDEN DIERPL
B.
TFINETSVET HAHACAAR RE
I 4, 3 IOO LTHHEK AL
Y.I
L T GOALNDKIS OFEA HHLT
.SUISES
THYOUS PH HETOU  T SDE IDAN
SANNU YOCAOTAV HERCAE NC, Y
G,YOE U'OU Y'EARE H
HYLT.R
INEYTH FOUD T LHEERAT, AVID D H
E
NCCA.ER
--DI HDCAAV HE
ERNC.
ITNOW AGS  ISTE IH  WV,IT
C.
>> SHILYAD T CISS AMOOMN
E
UGTHROUTHO V OUR'ERETAN'S
IESTOR
E ATWH WSEDNE IO  TED ENTH
EXO S,SE TKETA CE AROFUR O
VENS.
NGMAKIURE E PRIVUMESPT
E
TSNEBEFIMA IS TAIN.
THFOR E OSOFOU YHO W THI TNKSHI
TISHE WAY WARE ING E STOAV
STCOIL BS,Y TIMILUNANGOME
NCE THCA PS ERORRYMOULNA
SELNILESSN THT, LISISE H IAV
NEOR F YU , OUYOOTLLWI N
ATIST MPTHHO WITUT RNCISESTA
R
.IG FHT
THS  IS ATWH ITOINGOG
AVE
S.LIVE
ISTHATS  IWHINS  IGOGINO  TBR
GU
TOICSTE IDHE T WRES OWWE
CUTLYFE SUFRYNGRI T
G O
THISRAE MIR EIFA.LY
NK T>>HA
OU Y.
LAD  WSTOR TONHETI SECONWOO.
ANTHYOU R CLNGIFARYIS THI
IST ABE OUREE THRARSAN CCE
.
UMPRE ES AIOPTNSNG BREEI
T
WITH BTHY .V.E A.
STYOE U WIILTHS? U
GD DIHE
E >> HHAGHMIT T HVEADRUO NUT O
SO DTOO 1 9ME/1 BS.INUSES
RITO DE HVEOMIS HNT POII','
MGOE
GG INTOEIVOU Y TST WHEOR
ARSCEN.IO
RSE THWO PCAT SETISUREMP
IS
.THIS
BUSOMEALERWHE EG ONTH LE,IN
8 E THV-LLWIAY PEAHE T HSTH LTCO
ANEF BEN FITOR SEOOMNE --
OR F
R THEICALOCON ERN'AS WN'TSUR O
ARCENESSYILAU C BD SEBYNUR. PIT
TH IS RSE THWO SCAT SEO.NACERI
ERIN TPR OMSF IOUMESPT
ETH.A V. IODISTH B THAY VE
O
REHEVEMO TIRND BLIS.ER
THEVI EONNCDEE HE TCI CAR
S
ATHATTH IREN E SME OK
ISOV
MIWHEREL.NG
EDIN MALICS AP PERE TSOUID
E
ONNATIDE AALCA.MY
ITLL AS.XI EST
TH/1 91EA HHLTND ANSOM CPE
N
RAPROGTSEXM ISLLS  AWE
ATE ONTHPRS  IAPE RIOPATEYTH
EAULCOD ELYSI BOL F
WELOD.
HEIF TWAEL WL E.THS ER
ITORKSITS
IIVFEEFCT
IT
HOHERSNO TYEAX TPA I, RSITSOT
EFWASTFR OULR NTDUAULE
.OR F A
OUIF YRE ANGOO LKI
ONRESPBLSIEGR PROT  TAMHANCA
LPHELYIN FALSSDD AREHE T TICOP
--ICOXXP EUROSESUE ISSSITS I
ERTHE.
HA>> TNK.OU
ANIV-  -INW NOGOTOG  TE OVON
O
TLE
V.
NTI WAANO  TTHKLLOU Y AHEOR F T
DI OSIUSONETIN TL F.OR
HA>> TNKOU YRMCH, AI.AN
NKINERMEG MB M AND OBEEMRS
F
E MAKE2 Y TA TE  THEIM
TOLI
O ENST TE. HUSER
E THIZTHAUOR TEDHE V.A. TO
CO
SCUCNDT ICNTIEIFRCES REA
H,MI
CTALIRYRETEENR ONS WHIT
RBAIOXNEOR TS.IN
CR IITS ICALOR THE V
.O
HAVEO ET Y TBENT IDEIEIFDSTHA
E
AV.A. TTHT ISE.IM
ETH V..A WLIL --LIST EAB ASH
GIRASTTEC PNLA TOUR ENS
THEE
ARRESECO ICHS ATABLLORE,IV
ARANTRSPT AN COOEDINRDAT
H
OVT.SIERGH
THT POE IN TWAI NTOAKE,HE
V.A. H A RIOUTEPATNINF  OBE
GE
ARTIACON
WHIN TENRYGOVO  TPRREE IDCAOR F
NSTEVERAEN  ITHT, PASNNE  WCA
TLE - FWA- ITTH AORNO 4ER0 YRSEA
RFOGEHI TS ONRANETIF OORAR W-T
TRATENSIVREO CER THE EI
H
.CARE
ORANTRSFV.THM E A.EYO  STHAN C
TRTOORSFM C EXSUREHEINS  T
, TUFUREPRINBEG E.CTOAIV
RTHISH EAESRCT  WISHALOWS
TEMOMIET DERT  WNEHA
MMN
ILS ESLNSEEAR ANGECFFTIANET VER
O
Y.DA
WHMO CATOMERCAN NCSRE A
OS T
ET119/ VANS ING TO G
ET
NDINTEEARSIN 1S.YE5 AR
THISTATEAYNTME LG INTO C
S
RMDETEO EDIN TBEOSIT
ELIVY
TIIDENEDFIH WIT TOXOS EICXPEUR
NSTEVERA
WETOAV HE  AHI TNKAMUTBO F
S
ANDEP DSDEENNTF OER VETS.AN
GMAE IN TL OAOFSHIONEC STIS I
JEL WEOFES RTHRCEAH EYE, HAVWNRO
TH S ITIECON AWHS ATTHOWLLS
O
ATO  DTH
ANTHSOYOK U
UC MH.
>> TOUNKHA Y
AIAGMYWAN S  Q UIOSTN,ERND
TLTIE,  VA.E THV.EQ RWESTUES
KESTRI TLT HHEEACAH REEDTU SDI
T
THINATG SC NATO ORNCIEE
EVASCEEN HEE BN FNDOU
T THA
NNCOTSECDV AEASEER HHLT E,ECFFTS
THWIIG EIN AHTN ALVIDIDUN I
ERO TH EE.OSXPUR
TISS HIAE SITPUARE E
UG
ON BALOFF  OUREN DEP
NCD?
. Y>>ES
' 'M NOT
--
I'G GOM INE MTOOV OTO RKING
MEER BCOS.
>>HA TNK Y MR.MAHA CIR
N.I
O NTWA T OPAEXND.THN IS
ISTHS DI TCTREEDAROWD Y.OU
K THI INNTU YOMEITNEIOD URN  IYO
OPO G,IN DUYOVEEL BIEHA.A V.
E
RE AENGGIVSSE ETOUGNOH EUR PSU
TH RH EAESRCINGARERD
THG E
THHEALFF EFTSEC OOX TIC OS?ER
KI R>>ANNGBE MEMIS IR,T Y M
ONPERSAL -THILWHE  HV.E A.
AA
DE ASEMTTPTE , THANERAMIC
ONLEGI BS IEELVEE EFRTS
COBED OR ME
E THERBEULCOD OR ME EFFTS T
O
MBELLE ORCOIVORABAT TWIE TH
HS
UNCOO MMYITNCLU-NGDI -SO V
UNCOMMY,IT INGLUNCDIILHE T P
OT
OGPRT M,RA 'ULWOD'EEVE B
NAP
ECIAD.
EOSN IT WHIS E THVCTOU
COIEUNMMIT WS,EOT NRTHE EI
PA
NERTR.
AVWE HTO WK WITH TMHE
.
I D'O' TWAT NT OCOO ME
AFFS
INBEESDIG SRL CTPEFUORE RUD.
WEBE DO THEVLIE REITSFF EOR
COORBED  MABCOE LLE ATORIVDAN
ARANTRSPT.EN
>> T IANNKHI MERMEY MBEVBES LI
E
ETH --AT
THA TT,.OO
>> T ONENGHI, NG OM CINWNDO
RDO TOHA OV.THN E
BA.UT
KITHINSI ONGUT THE,  BOX
E
V.A., WEANON CSTLKY TLTA
BT
HOWOOVW ERHEEDRK T
ARY E.
ATWH WBO AUT IKIORNG
THN E
UNCOMMY.IT
HOW MYANALED MIC- -
AG EER
MESTCADIL  TENUDTSNTT HAWAO T
ARRESE,CH W GT ANTOIR TETHE
HA TINS TOSEHEHI TS.
WHCAN'TOR I W LWIK THALOC
LDIMECA SOOLSONNA, TIIS JALEW
JOTHAL, SHNKI HOP,NS THE
T
OGOES
RKD ANWOHEOG TET TWIR THHE. V.A
TOSOOVEME TH OMEF DE BATURONN
ETH.  V.AINOP HT  TESHAETH
ARRESE C CCHANFE OMOFERUI QCK
TTHATEA RHEESHRCNO IS INBAW CK
P
EAHE T HH CADS NEEF O
VE, RATENSKIMANGUR SEHE T
AE
G BEINCAKETAN
OREF.
ONETH OEROI PTH INTS EE IAT K
P?
YOINARG U SAY, O ATWH D
JURY'' ENVE- -E-CT AIVTYDUT
E,RVSEICS GOG TORDE  BHA
EO
O ET G T
EMTH.
EONADEN MY WEA HD,N HEIAS W
INGETTS ATG  ILLBIEDO
WA-  -I
E
QHAVENSSTUEIOO T A.SKIT
HIEREVYT INGST  THAOEYTH D
X-.YS
IAD HRAN  AX-Y OFY  M
ESCHT
BEI USCAE END HABE EOSXPED I
NPR
UGR IOCONDNGHI ARTO  SFO
D I HAISTHEOD NUL AA INODE IH.
WARE THE TNE, XT KNGHI 'W NOI'M
TTGEANG INSCSTH IN .IS
MITHE  WTALIRY OHOITUTFHA TTOU
-
OUWITHANY SCHA TT G.ENREIN
BEIUSCAE ID D GTH, EY
MOTE
BIDISA
TYLI.
ONMESO DT''SHARSTT
INOWG
TOSYMPIL UMSNTER AFT
RDWAS.
HEIF TTHHAY D ATNICR SEE,NGT I
'ULWODNB'T NGET GTID EN DIERFO
TSNEBEFI
DOWHY 'N'E LATHE ORAMFREW
KG
THR ISVE PREEATNTIV SCR
HTHATOMPSEL SHEOFE  T VSERETAN
INNOW OFEASTD ACET RRO.VETILY
>>LD Y IIE
AC BK.
>> TOUNKHA Y
>>HA T M YNKOUIR CR.HAHEN,MA T
A.V.OU WLDT AY S IEEREMO N
O
ONBE DARASE  FS A RH.EAESRC
IITNOS T ELY -
TH- E
REARSECHO  TT PPSUORREMO
TSNEBEFI
E THESPTESPRUME'I'ARS E C
,
WIYOU E  HLLAVEL ALTH T.E IMOF
YOOKLO AAGTHT E UROFE  O
VITSM NAVEHEND A TOO PRHEA HLT
THHEN,EI 'DOY N'VET HA T
O
GHFIPPANT  A IL EATORTHN EI
WEE,T USONN I TD,ILHAAN
LESETTWENTME, V''FIEE BN TING
2 FISORS.YE5 AR
ITNYT EPDEGIN
IT, OS VURET
DOH'T E  TVEIMTOTH GO
UGH
BOTHE D.AR
ETHSU PRE ITIMPONEREIS THO T
A ANGRT REDICTCEER SVI
ECCONNONTILIND A E TNAMITE
F ESAD OHAAYGR TTXI EST
E, THSH
CUTEN RITESUL, OS  ITO
COMPD CALITEDANY  THEN'D'
T
AKTO TSKA E RIRAND A GITINNTG
.
HEAT THOSO B, TIMAW Y VES MEHA
WENEE TDOLN'I , C'T
THEA RD .IS
ETHRD BOAORAS H MORAUE TH
IS
TO GNT.
>>HEOA BRD
--HI TISS
ATRPCOORURCUE LTHEATE  T
.,
DTHEYWANOO T NTANO  TGRTAGT EN
ORGE.
ROU VE S ETARG NNRUIN
T OUF
.TIME
LIWE SULEDPP FLYPORT S
N
43.
THD TEYOLENE  MWHE C IOM TO
DO, RKI T'N'INTHK WN T HACA
STO  TBE TER SVESHI VETIANER, IO
TCOME TWOO RKG NKHIINN W HOCA
I
ZEXIMAMIFOHI TS RE MIK-  -SO I
Y KEMA MSOOTQUA ' D IONG'T
TFI
D.RE
SIE THEAER YE  MOUAK T FITOR
HR
O ERIT THEKEMA TIR P TNTOIS,
EL LREIKYO  TE T GETH
AN.
ATTHS''OSY WHTHARE ELPO  SHELFU
ID ANSONTORMPTA
WERTUP SPOHE TTI SECON 4
ELI YI MBAD CK.TIY ME
>> IAV HESA E QUF ONTI IUYO
N'D', MIT NDAIRM.
>> YGNRER COE.IZ
S T>>HING GISOIAC BKO TETH
IOPREVUSIT T.
WACS,OTDOE  NRTUP SPO CGNGHAIN
THTRRCUEN FRKMERAWOOR F
METVINA VETTHANERS  B MATAY
E
PRD,ESOCSEISHA TT NTUR CRE
N
BOTHE S.
THIS N UHEERND T TWN OER
EDCKCT AIS LAE  MORCTSTRERIEIVPA
.LIPOCY
GOKLOINATT  ATHTU SDYAR E
E,
15FOR  TEA YRS. VHE.A A HAD
STINSHY OWG HNSERYPTEN AN
RGHHIERNESAT ITN VIE
EICRBIDXP EEDOSER VETS.AMHE
ACVENER OND TEUPHA TT S
DYT,
TEVENITUGHOH  CARLYS I
G OWGRINCHSEREAR
FROMAMHE T SETI SECD, ONANOR HON
AR,CKPAED STIECON05 4
NINCCOERFE BNGELRET VANERS,
R
MOTHE T, PSTARHI TSONEC STI- -
SSEDERTRMTOER VETSANR , FOETH
ARSTMO PTHISONEC STI
WH,T
MECOS FE M ROTHGO FOR V
ERN
UMPRESIVPTE C--IMLAS UL GFAR W
TEVEESN RAPRPTIVCLAI.MS
WWHATH TH LEGONLAISTIUE D
RE ATODDT TSSHA
?
METITH OMISTH C
TTMIEE
FOBE P TREHEC DEANMIOKTO.LA PCE
RIT BEREFOSHHE TY N DUTOW
CALLL TOHI
ER WE PDMIROSERO ABLD UNTATOE
S DRADESTTE THMA N AERNDEREV
.CAME
JUAU BSTECAR WSEE NGADE DI
ESPRE'PTUMI'S,  V TISHEIN. .AGO
O
E ABO  TSE TDOHE
ESPRESPTUMIV WREHES  THI
ILL
LENOT TOINADG  7 AIA D3%ENLE RAT
LIH  WITOBGLAL VSERETAN
CHNICLL IANSSNE, DE93D % ALNI
RATENDOR F UEDGNIAOS I.NELLSS
HA>> T M YNKOUWN BR.RO
NT LEUSE MOWOV ON  TTOHEEX N
TI
E.TL
'REHE'E S THGNKRAIN M
BEEMR.
OU>> WE LLDIKLO ATOPOOZEGI T
EREVI'NEYO,  'VEOTT O  TGE
AN THEOTR, VS HIIS
ALITLY
RTIMPOT.
IIL WINCOL NTUE TTOMOO NI,THR IS
I TEECPRIAHE T TEIMAT TO NDTE
Y.TODA
I E OGOLIZHAD ANI LE TVEO E.AV
NK T>>HA YKN, OUI R YOWOU
F
ITIS WHS. U
KITAAL INGN THL E ITIORNFMA
S
LL.
I TEECPRIAOU YR PTARICN.ATIPIO
'ITG'S G INTO SIT TLE.IX
RHPEUS APYO CAN CBIOMNER YOU
TA TS NTAT O EHEND
YOF UR
BBLIY RZEOGECNI -
>>NKHAHAOU Y C RMAIRN,
KG
ERMEMBND ARSEM MBEEF  OTH
CO
TEITE.
WEIE BELVE TXIT HATOSUEXC PO
RH
OTLDOU NBYE  BA T ODPRUC
OFSE
BICRVE,CE SUTINT IS, ITS I
PAIMCTIT -- PES  IIM TTIRAVE
OAD
THESDRS E ISE SUEATHWI HHLT
LURECA PEF BSENITS,IT WUTHO
LADEY.
RTIME POCEANF  O
ESTHE
ISPROVANNSIO C
T NOBE
RSUNDE
TETAD.
WEAKAN C MHE TSOOS MT DUN
ENPLIMEME THT ESSANCHGETILYO T
AG AWICYDE GNDET ITIORNFMA
ON
-- M ARE CBEEMRSEDTIONNUO T
FERER TOS LA CIMXIR FOTO
EX WSUPOREESNEITSSND A BNGEI
DEADD TTHO EN  BURGIT PIRE
.
TISOMEITS MEWAGOR F-  -
AS
THFOR AIR EICLBE TMSO EVIED.
THEESLSEN DIAOTRE A N
US JT
-CTIMENGSUONMIND A FTISTRURA,NG
ANEYTH CAK TECE PLA -- IDCOT UL
TA LHE TIRES.
ONDIADTILYAL, INGLUNCDIISN  ITH
PRISIOISN RE OUTHACUA G
IN
EAWE R OCHUT TOFRIS DENCHISEFI
NSTEVERALYMA, INITIN MORS.IE
ORPRIMAL --
RIMA MYORINIT
TEVEEVNSRA, ENUTIT WHOURXP EOS
O
UR BN P -- TOUAI STRTGH-
EAOUTRGEINCHG THINTTG O IISNT
THDS HRANAN CND A WVEL ILSA
LI
UE QIOSTN05 5,E  W TNTWAED
OAD
THESDRS ORFAE CTANAGS E
DGE
ACERND ROTISE  N ID LUNCDE
IH
ARREE SE.CH
ELWE BT VEIE IER IISMPFOIVATE
R
O R,SOEANSOM SE SCCIPEFI
ECIRAALNITHCUT BIN M
ITORY
RAVETENSRE AOR MECE SUSIBPTLE T
INIODD AIT A YN,OUVEO LSHA
HIES RERATF OANET VERSN I
RMBCOATES WRE TE Y HEARREMO
TKELILYBEO  E TOSXPEDETHO ES
TOICCHC EMS.AL
NGADDIAT RESPRS  AA NISOVIO I
SM
RATI.
INDD A IIOITN'NOT RYVE
AGVEESGRSIG GO, INCKBAO  TETH
ONESQUTIBO AUTERHE WTHR NOWE
IDPROVTHHEE ALNOAR CE
ANW D
BE AFINETSE  HNDAVISTH
SANVCOERONTIER LATSIT,  I
IMTHANRTT ATOBODGO IS GIN
AG DTOISTWE REBEEDN EENEO T B
EE
G IDOVIN CALHETHR E ARFO
ISES.
BUT G OKLOINATTO HISOM, RYFRHE T
TYNOMIRI VERETANER PVEECSPTI
YOEVERNEMI --  VRINOTYSERETAN,
AR OLEE FT.UT
WENUON CTIEO  TS, TDOHIEE  WAR
GOEETOG  SRIG HHEES RATF O
NIDEALMO AOR MNGINTEY ITVENSRA
LESS A
ESCCS.
URIN ONI OPI A, ONWEELOLBSUT
YHG
BE TVEO  DNGOI --E E  WAR
T  MTOEEOPE THSTGHP GARI
N.
AYSO ME EO PPLINE ARBETURN
AYAW
COMMOUT ENABNATHT E RTUTCOONTIAL
RISECUUE ITYSSARYO, U ECCOE RR
.
TAMILIER VRYETTES ANAFTTRR US
INNUTITIO T GKEO EPNG.
'I'THM A NED-IRGE
TIRAON
ICSERVR,EMEMBELLO  TTE MCHIL
VE STOERFT AEE IER S
HI TS?
THEY'OU WLD 'VE TD OLMEE. SHEAM
Y'NG GREOIO TIM L N TITHE
R
EOOF PREE PLWETOBL AE  IER SVE
H
TAMIE LI.
ET AAS VANER M IELYSF,OLAS W T
O
W OL FLOEYD ANOBLAW LFU
OR
RSDE.
WHO INGMAS KIODHE T DATO  DTH
?F
RE THES I A --HY W.SRE A U
.TN
EIPSOO BOS ENGXPTH TEDO
R OTHE
EAARS.
WHO  MAKREG INSUHE T
MEPADERT D ONTF IENEFSE
G OWLLINAMETH SEFU LAWLRD OSER
E U YOAR UKIASNGPHTOS  UD.OL
THISDOE D NSES RPOORLEIB F
PA FNGORHI T WS,E CFRNOANT
H
RAVEE TEEF BNSENS.IT
N WITAS OOTURLT FAUWE,
IF WGOARE E  GG INTOOOM SHEEWRE
THV.A.LLS  ITE TG INUSO GO,
-
IFDE  WHAAL WAYD KEAWE W
'ULWOD'EEVE BSEA N DE
ERRT.
W'ID DN'VET HAIC C AHO
WWEL E ERALTHUCSTK E.ERE.
U YOUANTCOINARY LLHEEEO PPL
O
I SAY ADS WAREYO  TR E DIFO
Y,UNCOTRN' D II'THI TWO INKT DUL
FPPHAENARE IVYES ADYERFT, GIN
ASUR ONIOM CMU'T'CYLES GA
AT IS1' 9/1L'S
CYGA.
HWE DE AVTOERBEO TTEPO  TKE
ATTHNAAT NIORISEL CUT. PTYAC
IFN E  WCATSEFF A SD ORTODEN
OPLEO WA WR,E T CANREE AKCA
M  TOFHEHEENWH T BCOY MEK.AC
>>NK THA, YOUUR. MSCH.
ULI WOLID KE T.T GEMRIT TUS T
P
UENPCU DISION  TITLEII V
SOE WAN CSSIS DCU SIT TLE
D
NSEVEOG T
HEETR.
I'VEEEN S MBMEERHETHWI T
IRHA
ISS NDRA.ED
YOINARU E HE TRUE Q.UE
>>BE MEM ORSFHE T WX HUP
EHI TS
IAPRAPECTEOU YNGOL HDI
UNRO DABDTLEIOCUISSSISTON  DSSCU
XITOCURXP EOS.ES
EXXITOC  RSUPOREISOREFM
ONG
E,EROVDULLE  WWI BCADEE DINGTI
CESOREURSO  TISTH I
UESS.
PPWE AE CIREATPOE THOPY UNRTIT
O
ARSHEITLEII.
N CTSEIO170ESRE CATLT H AEA
H
GISTRYOR F SCESTUBAN
E AS WMOARLEN REBO AUTS  THITHWI
EITHR CTYMUOMNITHHE, ALTREG RIS
S
.IT VAL
70IOCTN S SH2 OWDE LUSOA
D.
HO-- SWH UWSS
RE TIZGNESREREHE AVE O67R
TESIS TIE VHEARTO OTYF CXI
TASUBSESNC TTHAET VANANERS
EIR ESMIFALIEXER WE TOSEPOD D
OFRS YHEEA
INTRADG R AY ISEGTROR IISMPNTTA
CA WSOE GATHA  DAT
TOE
THHEAL CONDIONTIHOOFS  T
O
RVSEUNDEA VAOFETRIY
CICESTUMAN
CTSEN 70AND 470.
UI REQ
RERES
GRTPOIN ONCO -- NGECLLTI
INRMAT IN IOISNTORMPTASEEC BAU
ITNS ENESUR AER UNDNGANSTDIF O
EQIT RREREUIS RELAGUR G RTPOIN
N
ETH AY.URCCAC
WEOU ERENCBYGERAD HIHE T C.TS
ESE -- TNCPANSRE
ANY D
SIOVERTGH BFFNGEI O
EDER.
USBECAHEOFE  TE AT NUROF, WAR
TH AWIE LLAYS XP EUROSEO T
TADAIM LN.ATITIO
HOWE ST D ULNOHEKETA TGAIN
NSTEVERA
HI WS  TTEHIIM SISO RTAN
-IS- WLDSHE OUPOE  BEM
G
RAVETE S ANSNDVIERCE M TBEEMRS
I
NDAY A WTEO  TINITCTRA W
HTH
ALR EIHEOR RTHEC.DS
THE  HEYAVD LOALWEIATEPONTTOL
DOO, SE WI MAKE SISE URTH IS
IN ACTEFN FEY.E IVWA
THEONEC STIITINS  T W VLEIIKOR
TO AREDDSSER VET'A'LOOVS EREDOK
RFOATEN GER
NSIO.
AET BRER TECAUTOR F FEUR
TINEGERAS.ON
HEIF TER OUTHO -- E R NOTHCKPA
T ACISAS PD.SE
NK T>>HA
OU Y.
MSEN KAR.-  -MS KFRNAEEN
E
VFW TWA, NTENCOO MM TT HE
TI
>> YHA TNKIR COUHAN.MA
ITON TLEII VI,  TNKHIHA W
S
IDOESSEC RS NIOGZEOXATTH T
IC
EXS SUPOREENN CAEV OCC OUR
ICMEDOSTARIL MITY IATTANSLLN
.
STJUINOU TCHGK  BACLE TONITI, I
REESGNCOIZ -E TH- ERE LLWI BREMO
REPOEXSU
E THERREE ARALW Y ADNEREPOEXSU
.
ISTHE NT EIRHEMPCORE
IVNSE
AGPACKOISE  SRI CCAL,ECAU
H
ETITLII VARS  ISTNGTIINO  TPO
T
TORDS ATWH TEWSEHO NSHI TNG
ARE.
K THANU.YO
>> YHA TNK MOUS.EE KN.NA
AGO
ADHE.
>>HA TNK Y D, OUISNEERETMI
CSTJU A OMEOMNTNTI SEC,  SONIX
H
KIN TTLS HITIN'DOE ES
'T
NEILSSCEARASGEY T UC M
HAT
N.NTTEIO
ITEX IS Y EMTRELANPOIMRT
FOR
THHEALAR CE PRSVIRODEVEO  THA
TTBEIN TERRA TG INONICOX
SUEXPOLSS,RE AOOR F V
ANES
FIBENE A ATSNDTRINDMIS
IOATN
ONPERSL TOET BTRTEETR
G
TONTH OOPF SUEXE POS.RE
LTE THCUEUR AV.A.EEAS H B
NBR
UPGHOUT PL C AOUS.TIE ME
ITOM CTO TESO POC XIEXRESU
,AICLMST ISF NE O O.NIDEAL
ETHANET VERBIDIS SALATYLI C
IMT
OREMST WTT PKSRE OWEY LL
INTHGS,  FCEEXPTIC TOROX
EX
RESUS.
V'I'SE UHI TOGANS ALYEEF BOR, IF
CAJUADDIOKR TOLO CATS  AFIMLA O
A HOONRS W WAR AAS P
HUAE
MPJU AERNDAY 'YOS U'VEOT G
TR JNIAINGNDPSUM A'VE G
D
THE TINNCOEC S AONNDAY,  YESEMA
AI
SLYKE AYOOT N, R'U'NEAD B K
E
SE CREAUOUBYD  Y PRTEACARHU
JUHES,MP WNY  THET OKLO AEMESOON
POSETO BNUR F PIT
TORO
S YEARVED ANHAEAAN PCRCTI
NCER'TH, EY 'RELI WOTIL
O
YSATE H MOUAYEAVAD HANHE T CRCE
AN
AYYW.
WETOEE ND SUAK ME  A TREHE
PENEONL KEYW NOTHRAAN C G
NTR
EOSIM CLASTH IN  WSAE ME
TGREALA CR S IMFOALYSPHIC
DI.LIBITY
HA>> T. YNKOU
YHA TNK C MOUR.
IRHA.
HEBROT ARSNDRSIS STETHRO FM
E
MI,TALIRYNK THAOROU Y FOINI
AY TUSOD
ETHYOOR WK V'U'ON DE, OD TAYETH
CRSA YICIFES'O'E  MVEADINE ARGO
VEMP IROHEA HLTE  CAR
R Y
ILCHEN,  SONHEHE WN OM BECES
--HEHE WN OE GS IEO NTTH
MINDRYTA AS NT EER.MBCOAT
THISS ABE T OUTHARXTNE WS A
LLWE, YOUIFSAR CRREESIC AOT N
G GOINUN BTOE D.TINOCE
THA  IISS RYVEMO E TONTIAL
.
YOANTHK YOFOU R URSEDV AER- -
VOADANCYCA, THD E1 9/1
CO.SIISON
YOMPVEHA ITHVEROD S LIE VE
OF
IVNYMA GRE AEN GATEA DL O
F
IOTEATNTTON  TRIS HISESOU
T.BJSUEC
INGOGWA FORER, RDTHEDES  IA EEGR
PO ROFESIBILY DODOD ESE. HAV
TOWA AS RDOF TLLHENG YOUNDEN M A
WON WHSECHO OORVO  TSE
E.
THEY D'O'N TRT AIA BTOE
CIANLIND ATHHE WN  KICYOU
OUD  GT,OOCKLU,SP GODDWE, RE A
UNL ALCON NGTI OU.YO
HA>> TGOHAT S HATOT CE.NG
NOETERUL SANHOMEBED CO
AVE
RATEN W FHOITUTSTIR --
REA INIVG EDLLFU MORALIC WP.KU
UNATL TITHS,CC OURT I ITH ON
E
TAMILIEN, RYWHD E  WDIO IGONT
, MBCOATEU YOAREDXP EOSHEWH, ET
O
R'U'NGET GTIHO ST OUT-  -OTSH
ATLIIN, HA S ANGNYTOR O GESAS,
I
T NO THENSES RPOY ILIBIT
N
THE VD. .AAN TER VHEETSAN
LVEMTHSEPO TESO T T INOUATWH
REEYTH AXPOS TO.
ANWE CCET NOACT. TPTHA
AOV GNMENMUSTE B
TH --
EOF
INCEFIR E HA CRGOFLL TT
G GOINTOBA COMSA TT,O ERWEY  W
E
EXPOAKD,SE TRIHIE M TGH N,OW
NOHENGTI TCUOA RD EDRVBE NUM,RS
LLU YOWIKEE  BTACAN REOUF, O Y
WIAV HEO  THEVEHA T
SECO
TIERNVSAMOS ONA .RE
DYII ELK, BACOT G BEWADROVI
,YO
URFIAC SRIANS,CE MOFY  Y
OUHA
D HVEADFICUIES HETHWI T
THA.V., E-- D8  VNS. .AOW
A
LOT.
D YII EL
CKBA.
K THAN. U YOMR
AICHR.
A>>R YNDOUENNTSEIM.TS
--RE A IPPYOATCIE TI SUREN
.
H YDOOUEAVNY AST QUE
NSIO?
>> I JNTT USWAO T O ADDE MNEOR
THMRG .MAHA CIRERINN  T
F
ATALKHEUTBO TRCES REAHRSAT MTE
IN.LEIT V
ISTHFEA S LIITNGLO STIUAONA,
ST LOOFVIERCE M ABEEMRS
REEX
TOSEPOD  SOX TICCESTUBAN
S.WE
EE NDCO TO INNTUETSFF EOR
,CO
INUEESEAROH RCTHHOUGUT THE
LI
G THMEINMECA OUTBO A
AUTN
EAINCRDE ISEN  FNTMEIAVI SORER
SMBMEER EOSXPEDO  TORENAGT GEANE
S CADEDE
IOPRR.
INK THIWEHA TT TOEE ND  C
E
OLTO FESW LOTHESISE SU TOUGH
.
N TTOHETEXER GENOFIOATN
SEMBE ICMES.ER
>> TNKHA. YOU
>>IR CHA WN,MA ITANTH TO KANOU Y
FOPPISTH OTYTUORNI
NTWAANO  TTHTHALK L RAVEE TE
O
BEIN HD E ERANG ARSHINURYO
S ORSTIEDANOC ADVFOINATG R OUR
EN
INAVDEOR
MAS  IA FERTT ORI PANITORY
D
TEIN.IONTNS
VD ANWEURUEAL O V
ANERS
OVPREME IDTHTHIT WH BENETS
SSNECEY.AR
DOI T'N'ELIBEEVS OW N IMEE THTI
KE NTOICANL D D TE IMONHE
ISA ESSU, TTMAERF  ONDFELI A
DEOUFOH R RAVER TE.NS
ILS A TWAO NTASEMO PHEE IZTH
LUVAOF MINGUR SE WHESE U T
MOST EFFTIVECIEF, FIYST ENWA
NETOARSSY LEE  BABENO T BITEF
LALET V
ANERS.
E TO BO LEAB TRVSEEHE TM
ULLYMATITE,ACUTBO BIMTOK  T
ES
HENGRI THOU FRT OFUL JY
I,
ABLEEAO  TSPANTOK  MVETENS
ANDE  ABLK  TTOALTHOUABT
NEBETSFIHE TR'Y'SAEC NES.RY
ARERTHE  SMAE NY ORITOESLEPEF OP
THTO SP ME WHE EREY AOT N
SUITQUE T  WREHAFES WAAF
ING
EMTHHAT EY KMEW NESO
WRWAS G.ON
PTHISFCEIE OEGISTION,
ETH
NGNOHORIUR OACKED ACTAS,
CHANRMF O TCO SHEUBE ITMMTE
E
GYNOCHLOND AER MODONZANITII,
TBEENHE V.'.'STINS VEONTME T
CLINEUDHO T ISENHE TIS -- Y M
TADEUNRSISINNDG EXEE BN SEPODO T
OSTHETH --  SBAE ITEDUGTRGLO T
HA S TLEHEGEURONLA CSIM
,
ERFASTRO PSSINOF VSERETAN
CL.MS
. K ANAEEN,NDINDSYO IAYF
UO
WD,UL IIKLDOU LTOE EA HROU Y
E
IVPERSCT.ES
ON TORSUO PP IV.T A.IDPRN OVGIN
ETHEN BINITEFS  IUDCLEDN
THE
CKPAED ACT- -.
>>L W IILMPJU C IN,NAISHRTI
FR TTHA V.FW
PAS TT AROFEP IHEND
DEENNT
ETBUDGREWE,  AINLA PNNTOG
ENCOREMMTIADD DIALON F TDIUNNG
DEMOANIZRNE DAT UPDR THE EIT.I.O
STSYS TOEAL HETHWI TNTUR CRE
LOBACKGND F THETIOT PEN
AL
REFUTU IREASOXINE  T
ICEX
CSUPORE
IMLAS.
ISTHKES  ILIUL ALY MR-YTIOU
PR
ECOJT.
WE M ARETHINAKG RME OSFO
ENCOREMMSTIDAONHR THEGHOU TL
BUH WETIT P HERS.TNARER
IT-- WPAOUH R .NERTRS
>>SOE WALRTUP SPOHE T
ENCOREMM TTIDAONONC ITHASREE
ADGBUETNDRE DECE AS--ASNC IREE
H
E CYACAPIT OF
A-  -WE
REHE
FRINARG BE MOMEMOS ARSCR
E
BOARTHEYAIRE A WORNGTI F5 .
ARYES.
THEY D'O' HKNT OWG  LOWON
S
G GOINTOE. TAK
WELS AO KATW NOTHIGHE T E'H'
S
CHNOGYRA INFURRUSTCTISE
G CKLAINLYVESERE
IN OO ERRD THIKEMA TSN,AP HPEE W
EDNE TUIBEO  BTHINLDG
EST
ESCTRUUR N TOWOAB BE
TLO
ORSUPP TWHT ENESS HIDOO G
H.ROTHUG
W'AN C'E T USRGE THSUOFE IM CLA
S
N AXC ERE USFOOVOT N MISG INTH
LEN ATSLIORWAR
EYTHDYLR AEATHNO KW AN IISS
ISE.
VEU YOHA PO  TBEIZORRIITGIN TSHI
TOUR ENSE-  -,08000PLEOE
R
YE4.5 S ISBSUR
NGMAKITHUR SE PL PATEOHAVEHE
ITABILETTOY  GO T TOCS HIPRSES
IR TINHEIF L WIMETE,AYCHHI M
R
NOMAY ORBET  FAR5  .YE
>>' IG'M G T MCAO LLWN BR.RO
--WTHO.RN HTH -NE- HNETHAWOR
T>>O GU E IVYOMP EANXA
HW
RARE CHE TSECEANRS,  AREEDWOI RK
WIWO TREIF DFE. VNT.A
SEIEETCRARSO T A GET
RA BIN
ERCANC PTISUREMPED BVEASPO U
'A.V.'NS OW RH EAESRCTHR FOBOORF
NSTEVERA
PTHEYHUS TL S HIALETH WO T
E OFCE OGEMAF NANDNTME A
BUITETDG, ENAS W DDIE IN6. 201
DEWAS DIETHEDNI.N ID 7 01AN
ENEVTHIT WH
EA RESHRC V AND.
WA DG INTORITHO E TGHNG THI
OTHAU D RHEIEGE ANC
WHS OO
DI'D'FISET E RATOT  GDI FNTUN
O
R THE
NK T>>HAOROU Y FINRI BNG
TT
UP,HI I TNKOROU Y FINRI BNG
G
THMP EATXA
ULEP.
MR.ORAW CTH
>> YHA TNKY VOUER
CHMU.
OFUR OSEEP RREESATNTIVI
APIAECTEEIOU Y BE, HNGER
IWO
KED ULLI T TJOO INSHI
ESQUWIONTI,  TTHHE O VFWAT
NDLIHEY,SA WD WON ULUYO BIEVE
DEHE T IAL TEIM TO T
RAVETE'N'O  NHEENWH T
ARY E
ELIBLEHAND A WFIBET NE
TY
ARE BLEILDEY-  -THLIRE A E
E
FOR QN CKUI ISGARERDBU TO
RN
?PITS
HERO B GHTUG ALAATRE PY O
FEN
NIGHLITE I ANGNDORMI THE
SO WIELDRSEYN HETHR''NGEA LVI
TH S TVIERCEMEBEO COET V
,
HEENWH TLDSHY OUABAR WN LT OUAL
ESTHE.
OKI LORDOR FWAYOO  TAN
WNO
WA AS NTTOWENSRT. THA
I>>JUIL WL IMPNLYUI QCK
DUNGRIHE TDAC PKE P, GRROAM
S
TONOT Y.EAO RL
S DITOE HEDE AVCR S AITND
E
OON NRY TERLLNS ITAIONS
TIA ME T FORIRHE BEFITREBES FO
THHADIR SCE.RG
EATHE  TIERLR,TE BHEET
SOMEEF  OTHPL COMWENTAIS V''
HEWID THET VANERSS  ICKE THLA
OFTIORNFMA.ON
R ETWHHEITS  IH ROTHUG
AIE,
NOTECHGY OUS JHEATT  T
.
T  WONHABEEITHR FINETS A
D
TWHATNY HECAIF DO Y  THEELIBEEV
THEXER WE TOSEPOD
OX TIC
TASUBS
ESNC.
ERTHEY EA RLLN'I'INA T POOFT
METIITHA TT S IAROO T E,LY
RETWHHET  IISRVN- ISEEIC
RVIC AS REEYTH A
TRONSIANTI AG INORT F THESTIR
INT  C WTAONCTEH ITTH
DE OMERTNTRAVEF TEAI ANSFF.
I>> TGR AEEET HATH ASS IUETHE
TRANINTISIONGSERO FM
ICRV.
VAS AERETAN MELYSF,OU I W SAY
HEREFO TYON GO YMEP DLOT.EN
WE SULD NGAL TKI TBO AUTICOX
REPOEXSU BANOREFE SNEYO I
EXD.SE
WE SULD PTVEHA O
NSIO.
' DWEONH'T OP AVEN O ONTI TLKWA
AY.
WE D'O' THAT VEIO OHEPTALTON  W
W
AYM FROT, POSBUR  OA . PRNIT
FOBETI GREETNGOS EXPD , EDAN
AT
H WPEAPNSOULEHI YR''NRE A O
MEPLDEOYIN ONTR ERHE TAT
YOU
LDSHOULDE  BTOYOHE WN
ARU E
INLEAV
WHERE ILTH S YE,OUBEULHOD
D
.MORE
ATTHGO IS G INTO IERENCAS
PRTIENONND A DAR ELYONECETTI
.
AT IENHAS PPGINOW NLEPE, OP
GE54.EA Y Y, RS10RSEA
POSTPOEXNDRESU AARHE TY G.DYE IN
E Y WHARWEOOOT N LT NGKI AISTH
10 YGORSEA ATHHE WN  WER
EXATSEPOD G AK MINHERESU T
E
TOTHE EYS OLTHTOEE ND EAN MAG
SATWH IG?OM CIN
LDSHOUE OT N BUGHTFF GRDUA
BYCE CANORR A ST AHM SOMHING
TH'ER WENE'T G CTPEINODENWH D
EWKNEARSGO.
T>>NKHAOU Y
G'M  GG INTOO TOS -  -HI
S
IRUP F.ST
ILPH. HAD
>>HA TNKOU Y, .RMAIAN
I MA TNTO  AME COM
INTN
REREFEE NCTOREHA WT TAESPRENVETI
RAN S S IINAYG,..T
TRFRINAS, TUUCREOR IASMP
NT.
CTHEYLDOU H,0E IR10E M00OR
PELE TO HF P,EL I' DWEONH'T
H
EOO TEX TLSO  TDIPETE
SOCPRESOW N, WINE ARGOETOG  B
IN OOR WLD.HUF RT
THE ARER  OVE0 0,2000GCKBALO
CLAY TMSOD
ISTHHES  IA YAVESTMT IN
V.STNF IRAE,CTRUUR
.T I.
EIIS BTE TNGESDUT O THENARI OGI
F
HOWE S HD ULBE IVIEALYNGESNVTI
INHA TTO  SWETE WHIN --
NE ,
N'D' BHAT VEKLACOGLA CSIM.
HOWE S PD ULBEINGAD AHEO S T
S EMST IUPHA TO HALEND W
R
S COMEISTHAY W IXITOCEDXP EOS
VEOPN RASTHENGPI T.RI PCE
PATO SP NG T PRI.CE
HA>> T YNKOUHAIRN
RI CAR
T
T LEASRS Y12EA AGO, TASREHE W
PRMEPLDEOYIN TNTRADG INAN
EPSTPO-DTYMLOENIN TRAGIN
.
THTH IATS ECPEE RFT T
E IMO
ATEDUCEUT ABOAIHA WT
ORRBE
NSTOXINORE A KWN THEBEO  W
RETH
'E' GNGOI,HE WT ERTH I AIS
MPHL, AOW PT POERINT JORUS
TAO T C THENPSORMAOC DHIK,S
ISNGETOMHISHHA TT ELDOU B
ENGHOUEPRE P-DT YMLOENDAN
EPSTPO-DT YMLOENNGAITRNI
>>U F IYON'D' MMIT NDNGASE KI
U
LLK ICFO-UOWPST QUEN,
ERGFOIVG Y  MEG, ANGRTSER NOFEV
SEED B
OREFE.
R OU TOPPELEEIREHE BNGEPLOD,
HEDO TIR TGINRAIN, D THW KEYNO
ISPIUR BN TIV ACTE ASE TREHE
AIATNEOR P AGEHONSTH IREN
EAR
?EA
>> E C IANLAXPINATO TWH
IRE
FMBMEER YM RO12RSEA AGO
.
WAI JUTHS E ORNIPO CORL.RA
SOSTIMEMEOU YUN VOL
ERTES
TISOMEU S MEYOTGEUN VOLE
OLD.
RNE THBU W BANELDOU BULL
WHEM IAT RTHBEEMR  WMOE STEER
PEVEENLO
WHYET R  YATOUSREPANTSSDD ARE,ES
RIURYO FDSEN AESREDDSS TO TGE
TOUIGND A ENE, HTZO
SE IITS  TRICUTYECPRO OT
THE
RMINFO
IOATN.
OONCEE TWR ICAK  WEEED EITNDP U
OMFRTAOX B, KET  I J TTOHE
R
ATPRIVHEINE  TQU S
ROADN.
PTHATDR OOKILD WOUTOAV HE O G
THTCWAH BUE RN PITND ARE B
G
', I'M SU HE VENTWE EEE TRYHR
DAYSEVWH, EN B TERHEX N URBOTHWI
FOILRN-  -BUOX BIL FL
.
S ATTH IY REMBER
>> YSKRE A A CG INIFERMAOMND
N
UT AOWBO TS.
THOVDOE D ALERL A NEWHIUTBO T
ETR CON STOACRSHERTTA T
N
PITS, KEMA T S DHEODLEN IGA ERTT
ATSTATG INTHODHE T D GEV NER
O
NDCKBA A PAGSUURE THNSAIT
NTCO FCTRAORORHE TPIUR BN .TS
IHERELITHS E TH OSTF NKNE OW
SFEEFCTF OOX TOS EICXPESUR
'EYTH'OIRE GNGCO TO M  FMERO
E
PBURNATS ITTHOU CLD F
THUR
CAEUS -DOTH- E DE S  ITHEON
G GNSIINESTHEON C.ACTRTS
TE PTOROCT TTR CHEONTORS
THUSCAE W  KEYNOD W HOBA
E
ARE.
>>HA TNK. YOU
NK T>>HACHMRS . .RMAIAN
NTI WASPO  TREDONO COMARENGSS
CAWTHERNHO, SK AED M FORTINY PUN
ONST QISUE WN IOASL.EL
ANIT CT''BEAROO T EST TLYO TAR
G LLTEIN AOPPELEHEUTBO T
SEIS
ESSU.
MNOHOTEATR WD,OOEC ESP
LY
TETHE UE INSSS P, GRROAM
IS
YSALWA TOI GNGOOBEO  T
UC MH
RMINFOIOATN.
VEU YOHANTO  TCOO UEIN TLLTE
EMTHER AFTRDWAS
.
THEE ESAR QNSSTUEIOHE PMARY
CAR OC DTO BOUSHLDNGHAE VI
SIT IOOEREV T BAR ELY IUTTS
NGDURIFTND A AWE AERS .LL
THG CKBALOOUISTH C
LLNTTEIA C WATREE,E' DONPO
'T
TLIKE.  VHE.AE HTOAVKL BAC,OG
HEENWH T'R'NOS  R
SOEAN.
MESOOGAC BKLGOARS E ODOGAC BKL
EOS ASE TREHORE CBEINATG
E
REWE A G RTIETNGETHTIG V
ANS
INTOHE S
TEYSM.
THE'E'MPA S TEBAARORY LOG
EACRDTE, TOTIST  NSAEC NESLYRI
NCCON.ER
>>' IG'M GG INTOU E IVYOETH
ORSTLA W
MELET US JTAY TRE I ASUS CH
TH TG INISHEITEN BEFTH OF
EHASCRGRO PHIAMGR WID ICH DEDI
SEINIO ACTNUR DGIN
ATTHOE DSE  MAKAOO GD AOPTEM T
DERITEN BEFUPS ONARIS DCHGE,
HEVEGI T V AERETANCAHY PSI
INUDCLEHE TCTUB SJEATTEOFOT N.
Y.TODA
IITS LUNCDEEL ALTH BENITS,
INMESOTH--G  REFLOOINNGEIECVI
ZERO
--
VAIS A OABILLESON MEAS B
SN
PSOME BCELAS, NUTOT EERRYVEWH
.
OTESDO NOLVEHIS OFSUISE LL A
ROU VSERETANOS EXPBU TEDO
RN
N TSPI IE PO-9/11 ETH IRAN
E
BEESOIE PAT.NT
ENCOI MMD YTIOR F S
INCKG
TH
UGROH.
T NOREENEV ARSEM MBENGF  OCOSSRE
TOHA TT-  -DO
HA TT.
>>' 'EDINM CROPLYIB P
ARUL.
THFAOU ICT WLD RDOHEATR
S
IS AOT RE SEISRI MTOYNATA SMI
.
-- AMEES TTAMY TNTO NATA SMI
>>AL TKUTBOHN TECANOGOLY
DCAL
ACIPATYNDOU RESESRCTH,
COK BMEAC TO F ONENTDAUNME
AL
EETR ITH, ATRIPRS IO.TY
RIPRIO I ATYNDONENNTTI
WE KP HEFRINARG OM CS,GRONES
PE OLEF THEGOEN PTAANN D D,OD
ABOU A TTHEOFUNMOT E EO PPLATTH
CY MABEFOINOMG
ARRWD.
'W'N  BVEEE F WATAR 2OR0 Y.RS
D DOIS THE M ONETHINAKG 'V.E A'S
OMCUSTS.ER
THIS AOU CLDSE BLLE IN CENOM
G
FR M 1OM00ESILY. AWA
ANDOD OTBAD  BHW, KNE
HE TR
RNINTEUM DALOCHOTSEN SW08N  I20
AN2010HE TIC TOXR OR FGE
A
LYDEADAZ HR D ARFOERIC
.OOTRPS
GHE FEEINEW AT WASIN COM
GH
E THERS  TISHITYPACACIRC SEAH
O ATTH NDEE ONUN OTORSOD
SAW
CONG,  IITS
- THE- ISIST  A
THY  TGHHEILREWE FNGLIP U
TUBATHYEFOB R SARN  THEHANTWE W
S
LL A TTES HIWAHEONR  T?LO FOR
'WE 'VE WN EEAT 2 FARORS.YE0 AR
THE E ERARLL5 3.MITEN IOVE
.
EYTH GHE TSEURNTIA B.PIN TS
LLWE ANE K WTHW ISIN CASOM
THEDE IAVWEA  H'E'
BET EN
DIBUILAC CNGAP TY ITUPHIO T
S
PO NT INISNTLIEGGE
D ANODEREVYB'Y'T. PAR
I K THGEES MSA, DE THDO H
N
OUNO ERM TPAS RT IPLO AYN TSHI
O  AISLS
UETR.
DOHEISD  TNE ORE WHE'HE TRE'S,.A
STALMOO NRS OVEVEHTIG O
THRE
IVMASSERCES ROUT  TESHAEYTH
.
THAND SOE OSRECEURS HE TBEO
O EDUS TNNFUELO INT V H. .ATOPEL
AKEMTH TEE  CAR TOFHEDI SOLSER
DANOT NFOUS JT ADE RCREESINS,
RTT BUPAF OIO NATCUL NASETYRI
D ANRERCFOE S INADES T TISHESTRU
ILREBU TWID THER VHEET
AN
COY UNMMITATTHOU YIV LE
P O
OBTHE ONGALITITHEYAVE
D
O.UP T
NAE THFIT POL INHN TISEC
O.
THISS  IEE THON TTHAE S  ITHSTMO
IVFOUNRG
LEAB.
GOFOR DAK S,ES Y D GOUOT
PA,
PETHE , AGNTONOTEYTH GOBOT
UTGSDO O THE TREINRYG TREFIO GU
OUHOW TUSDIO FFS MIE NDTYEOD D
S'NDCO'S -FMESO O TSE A
N YSGU OITPETYWRS.ER
ND SITOU ALIS KE JEOK.
WHFLT  IRESTSEC I
HI TS,
RIPRIO.TY
THANMEE N DOM W WENHO SERED VEAR
THSTEAGRTESS AETTH OF EDUNE IT
STIT MESILY.AR
ANDET Y,Y  THEE E ARTH OWELOST
H
MTOE TEWHOL PE ES CENOMO T
CESOREUR
WES LW AAYVEHA M T FEYOR
TEGYNOCHLODETH, E
NSFEEHE
RACONTORCTS,H  WITIGVESORE
N
MUNI T FTYOREN DHEEF
SECO
ORRANTCT
AN BWEAL B TCEHEGEUDTEN  OTH
BAHOOFS  T C WSEHOEOMANOM HE
D
Y TOEGEI RNT
TERA.
THATS  IETHNG CHALTG INCUEUR
ASATTH HKEO  TTA.LA PCE
I' IOW'M TKIALNGO
TIAHE T V
SEHEND A TRE RIREPIVNTSEAT
ER
EON GE,
IT  CRAAR WZYE
EHA
HINGVI TINMES ET
I'M TH IKFANULETIST  GNGTION D
,
ASISTH HTO  TGEONE S D ANHA
E
TWION DE MO CTHOMN SNDSEEN A
INLIIONTNA.TY
K THANRYU YOVEFOUC MH NGHAR VI
US --G AV HINITISTH, CHS  IMU
APD.IAECTE
>>OUNKHA YTER. M S
RTWA.
POYOU TIN T OUTRK SHETA
NTCOIODIRACT.NS
I ONTWA TO ECH SHAOFE  WTHE
AIORCT SDERAR ELI
THOUABT EON CRSACTRTOAEEN HA TT
EDSIGNOCUMTSAY SEYG INTH
WO'D'ELBET  HLELID AB
D IDOELTSF  F NESOTLAL UERND
MEE THSAEG RNSATULIOTHHE T O
EU
ESNESISSE N  ITHITEDTATE
S
FOERND -NDLLFA U.ER
THEY WEVLDOU NE  HERAVDLOALWE
TEEXISL PPIN  B--URRITSPI T
BUF IT P OZEE THSIOU Y
NENTMEIOIEEAD RLLYSIR MP
OD
NOTEOL TATERED IBOTHN E DSUN
U TOFHESTTENID F ESAT OA.ERAMIC
T BUD CADO ITAU BEC
'E' NREOTOU BND B
OSY HA
RELATIS.ON
ES  IANTOITNTY F.TS IEL
I O NTWA TEAANTHK  OCHF F YOU
H
ISIS DN.SSCUIO
WHEN ONT CUROUS  GRYOETOAR WWE,
N'D'TIT HES PE ATTO G FAYORSUN
NEEDTTHKSAN, RVR EISEMBE ICMESER
YT,OUNO KS  GW,UNNKD ANTA
E TY  OHENLSTCO A
AR W.SAR
USWE MREENT SUEPE  WKEUR O
E OMPRISIC TTOOXTS
OS PED
TEVENSRASHHE TY'LDOUN'VET HA T
GHFIT V C. .AORS GRONESER FOTH
BEHETSFI TV'Y'NE EAR
AND D
RVDESE.ED
ARNO MONNGKI CESGRSRY COR F
ALYSPHICAIES RTRES CNTOM T
ORNGRI FETUR O V
ANERS.
--LAIS FCRARE  STENT INWHT I
CO CS METOFOINARG
OUR R
RAVETE.NS
T  WDOANTO
HA TNK R THE
KG
MBME AERND T ALLHE RCAUBEPLI
NME
ERS D STFAF A
ATICRTIPTOG INI'AT DE'SPA
ETMEG.IN
--'OD TAYM'S
INETG.
S IT IE  HMYOPWECOIL WL
ME
GETH S AERNDITAKPE WAH
DIFUNIEOI VCE.
D MA VETARANERS EOR PRIY.IT
--RIUR O P
ITORY.
THWI IHA TT,''NG GOILLO  TCA
THEEPRE OCTONGDIS .LO CSE
K THANLU YOALOR F
OU YR
ICPARTN ATIPIOGACEON A.IN
ANK U.
INENPEDEND